we become preoccupied with other
important things our collective memory
is short this three months ago this
country was preoccupied with impeaching
president
now that seems like ancient Roman
history
now while this crisis has our full
attention I believe we should put into
law this year
whatever improvements need to be made to
be well prepared for the next endemic if
there is to be finger-pointing hope
they're pointed in that direction
fortunate today to have four
distinguished witnesses we're at the
heart of the response the coronavirus
were grateful for their service to our
country I've asked to meet you to
summarize their remarks in five minutes
then we'll have five minute round of
questions from each senator I've agreed
we'll end our hearing about 12:30 after
we have a full round of questions every
senator will have a chance to have his
or her five minutes senator Murray will
then have an opportunity to ask the last
question or to close the hearing and I
will then close the hearing there will
be other hearings to follow this hearing
like last Thursday's hearing and
Senators may submit their questions in
writing within the next ten days staying
at home indefinitely is not the solution
to this pandemic there's not enough
money available to help all those hurt
by a closed economy all roads back to
work back to school lead through testing
cracking isolation treatment and
vaccines
this requires widespread testing
millions more tests created mostly by
new technologies to identify those who
are sick and who've been exposed so they
can be quarantined and by containing the
disease in this way give the rest of
America
enough confidence to go back to working
school for the near term help make sure
those 31,000 UT students and faculty
members show up in August we need
widespread testing millions more tests
created mostly by new technologies who
identified those who are sick who have
been exposed so they can be quarantined
back in
the disease in this way give the rest of
America enough confidence to go back to
work and back to school
senator Murray well thank you very much
mr. chairman my thoughts are with you
and your team right now as you try to
navigate the same challenge so many in
our country are worried about
we all wish your staff member a speedy
recovery and as everyone works to take
appropriate safety precautions today I'd
like to thank not only our witnesses for
joining us today but also our committee
staff for working to set up a safe
format for members and witnesses and the
public to participate in this hearing
remotely families across the country are
counting on us for the truth about the
Cova 19 pandemic especially since it is
clear they will not get it from
presidents not truth is essential so
people have the facts so they can make
decisions for themselves and their
families and their communities lives are
at stake the president isn't telling the
truth we must and our witnesses must and
we're counting on you today and families
need us to take this opportunity to dig
into the facts about where things did go
wrong so we can finally get them on
track because the Trump administration's
response to this public health emergency
so far has been a disaster on its own
delays missteps have put us way behind
where we need to be on diagnostic tests
and allowed inaccurate antibody tests
that flood the market corruption and
political interference have impeded
efforts to secure desperately needed
personal protective equipment and
promoted dangerous unproven treatments
and we recently learned that after
experts at the Centers for Disease
Control and Prevention spent weeks
developing a detailed guide to help our
communities understand how to safely
reopen when the time comes the Trump
administration tossed it in the trash
bin for being to prescribe
but this is far from the first time this
administration has silenced experts who
were doing their job and putting public
health first the fact of the matter is
President Trump has been more focused on
fighting against the truth than fighting
this virus and Americans have sadly paid
the price
since this committee last heard from
these witnesses on March 3rd we have
seen over 900 deaths in my home state of
Washington over 80 thousand deaths
nationally and the numbers continue to
climb still president Trump is trying to
ignore the facts and ignore the experts
who've been very clear we are nowhere
close to where we need to be to reopen
safely my hope today is that we can cut
through this and have a serious
discussion about what is needed to
safely open how close we are as a
country to meeting those needs and how
we actually get there one thing that's
abundantly clear
we need dramatically more testing it is
unacceptable we still don't have a
national strategic plan to make sure
testing is free fast and everywhere that
is why I thought to make sure our last
kovin 19 package included an initial 25
billion dollars testing fund and a
requirement that the administration
submit a plan by May 24th and when I say
a plan I don't mean a PR plan I mean a
plan with specific timelines and numeric
goals for supply and funding needs one
that actually addresses the issues were
seeing on testing capacity and
distribution and disparities and
building out our public health system
and makes clear to states and tribes and
employers and the American people what
they can expect and what the
administration will do to keep Americans
safe but testing alone won't be enough
to reopen our country we still need far
more personal protective equipment that
has been available for our health care
workers on the frontlines and we will
need far more for other workers
we reopened so we desperately need this
administration to step up and get that
equipment to states who are doing
everything in their power to purchase
supplies but simply cannot get nearly
enough because the reality is unlike
states the federal government has the
tools to actually fix the problem if
only the administration would use them
and we also need that equipment to
actually work and for the FDA to act
promptly if it does not not weeks later
when people may have already been
exposed and just as importantly we can't
expect people to go back to work or to
restaurants or to confidently send their
kids to school if there isn't clear
detailed guidance about how to do that
safely schools from early childhood
through college need to know how to keep
their students their staff and their
educators safe when should they wear
masks how do you run a school cafeteria
or a school bus and if they can't reopen
classrooms schools and Families need to
know we are working to ensure every
student gets an education feels like
online learning can only get us so far
if we don't address the digital divide
that so that every student can access
them and even then there will be
learning loss that could deepen existing
educational disparities among low income
students students with disabilities
English language learners and other
vulnerable populations if we don't make
sure they get equal access to resources
and support and of course schools aren't
the only workplaces we've got to be
thinking about we need to make sure that
industries across the country know how
to safely reopen and that people know
their workplace is safe
secretary Scalia needs to stop dragging
his feet and do his job and have the
Department of Labor set forward a rule
that makes clear worker safety is not
optional mr. chairman I hope this
committee can hear about those critical
secretary Scalia and secretary gave us
as well as other experts in the space in
the days ahead and this is especially
important to protect workers and
residents at our nursing homes and other
congregate care facilities who
we've seen some of the most deadly
outbreaks and as the rash of outbreaks
that meatpacking plants shows this isn't
just an issue for the healthcare
industry it is an issue for everyone and
justice we need a plan before we can
start to reopen we also need a plan well
before we have a safe and effective
vaccine to guarantee that we can quickly
produce and distribute it on a global
scale and make it free and available for
everyone so I'll be asking about our
progress on those issues today today
safely reopening our country may be a
ways off and the administration's
planning may be way behind but there's
still a lot that Congress needs to do
there isn't time to spare some including
the White House say we've already
provided enough economic relief my
question to them is what good is a
bridge that only gets you to the middle
of the river we don't need to wait
around to see if people need more help
we know they do we need to work quickly
on another aggressive relief package and
we need to make sure our priorities in
that bill are protecting our workers our
students and our families and addressing
this public health crisis not bailing
out corporations or protecting big
business from accountability people
across the country are doing their part
they are washing their hands and wearing
masks and social distancing and staying
home they need their government to do
its part too they need leadership they
need a plan they need honesty and they
need it now before we reopen so they can
rest assured that we are doing things
safely and confidently with their health
and well-being as a top priority Thank
You mr. chairman
deceiving it's an important hearing and
I know lots of people may be watching it
for the first time if they are I hope
they notice that we have 23 members of
this committee I believe one more
republican than democrat we have some
very strong views but we're able to work
together and to express those views and
respect each other and our witnesses and
that and a big part of that goes to
Senator Murray and her staff so thank
you for that each witness will have up
to five minutes to give his his
testimony thank you for making an
exception it agreeing to testify by
video because of these unusual
circumstances and thank you for what
you're doing for our country our first
with witnesses dr. Anthony ouchy a he's
director of the National Institutes of
Allergy and Infectious Diseases with the
National Institutes of Health he's held
that positions for not since 1984 which
meant he's advised six presidents and
worked on HIV AIDS influenza malaria
Ebola and other infectious infectious
diseases he was involved in treating
Ebola patients at NIH and also worked on
vaccine trials for Ebola next we'll hear
from dr. Robert Redfield he's director
of the US Centers for Disease Control
and Prevention which has its
headquarters in Atlanta more than 30
years he's been involved with clinical
research related to chronic human viral
infections infections diseases
especially HIV he was the founding
director of the department of retroviral
research within the US military's HIV
research program he spent 20 years with
the US Army Medical Corps third admiral
brett jawad jawad admiral Jawa is
assistant secretary for health at the US
Department of Health and Human Services
that puts him in charge of development
of public health policy recommendations
he's taken on the responsibility for
coordinating testing and focused on the
increasing number of tests that we can
do with existing technology his federal
service includes a variety of activities
with our Defense
Department in Advanced Research threat
reduction he was part of a blue-ribbon
panel
reformed the u.s. veteran's health
system and finally we will hear from dr.
Steven Hahn he's Commissioner of the
Food and Drug Administration for joining
FDA he was the chief medical Executive
the University of Texas MD Anderson
Cancer Center he was chair of the
department of radiation oncology at the
University of Pennsylvania was a senior
investigator at the National Institutes
of Health as commander of the US Public
Health Service commissioned Corps from
2025
now we'll ask each of our witnesses to
summarize their remarks in five minutes
following that each senator will have
five minutes for question and answers in
order of seniority
dr. Falchi let's begin with you welcome
thank you very much mr. chairman ranking
member Murray and members of the
committee thank you for giving me the
opportunity to discuss with you today
the role the National Institutes of
Health in research addressing cope at 19
a strategic plan that we have is
fourfold one to improve a fundamental
knowledge of the virus and the disease
it causes next to develop new point of
care Diagnostics next to characterize
and test therapeutics and finally
develop safe and effective vaccines
first with regard to Diagnostics as you
probably heard from dr. Francis Collins
last Thursday the NIH has developed a
rapid acceleration of Diagnostics
program called red X with an award to
that specific program up to a half a
billion dollars to support the
development of kovat 19 Diagnostics
it is a national call innovative
technologies that would be evaluated in
a shark tank like selection process to
get to either success or failure rapidly
moving on to therapeutics I'll talk a
bit about the rim desapear success
antiviral in a moment but let me
emphasize that there are a number of
spectrum antivirals that are in various
stages of testing in addition who will
be looking at convalescent plasma which
is plasma from individuals were
recovered from kovat 19 to be used in
passive transfer either in prevention or
treatment in addition our immune
globulin which can be used as a gamma
globulin shot we'll be looking at
repurposed drugs as well as immune based
therapies and host modifiers and finally
monoclonal antibodies let me take a
moment to describe them Desa via osebo
control randomized trial which was done
internationally with a power of more
than a thousand individuals and sites
throughout the world it was in
hospitalized patients with lung disease
the endpoint was primarily time to
recovery the result was statistically
significant but really modest and we
must remember it was only a modest
result showing that the drug made a 31%
faster time the recovery we hope to
build on this modest success with
combinations of drugs and better drugs
moving on to vaccines there are at least
eight candidate copa 19 back scenes in
clinical development the NIH has been
collaborating with a number of
pharmaceutical companies at various
stages of development I will describe
one very briefly which is not the only
one a one that we have been involved in
heavily developing with more Danner
it's a messenger RNA platform you might
recall in this committee that in January
of this year I said that it would take
about one year to 18 months if we were
successful in developing a vaccine the
NIH trial moved very quickly on January
10th the sequence was known On January
the 11th the vaccine research center met
to develop a plan on the 14th of January
we officially started the vaccine
development sixty two days later we are
now in Phase one clinical trial with the
two doses already fully enrolled there
will be animal safety the phase one will
directly go into phase
two three in late spring and early
summer and if we are successful we hope
to know that in the late fall and early
winter there are some important issues
however in kovat 19 vaccine development
we have many candidates and hope to have
multiple winners in other words its
multiple shots on goal this will be
important because this will be good for
global availability if we have more than
one successful candidate we also as the
chairman mentioned will be producing
vaccine at risk which means we'll be
investigating considerable resources in
developing doses even before we know any
given candidate or candidates work I
must warn that there's also the
possibility of negative consequences but
certain vaccines can actually enhance
the negative effect of the infection the
big unknown is efficacy will it be
present or absence and how durable will
it be and finally I want to mention the
NIH has launched a public-private
partnership called accelerating Cova 19
the reputed interventions and vaccines
the purpose of that is to prioritize and
accelerate clinical evaluation of
therapeutic candidates with near-term
potential hopefully our research efforts
together with the other public health
efforts will get us quickly to an end to
this terrible ordeal that we are all
going through thank you very much happy
to answer questions later thank you dr.
edsen well good morning chairman
Alexander and ranking member Murray and
members of the committee our nation is
confronting the most serious public
health crisis in more than a century yet
we're not defenseless we have powerful
tools to fight the sentiment imme we
have tried and true effective public
health interventions such as early case
identification isolation and contact
tracing combined with important
mitigation strategy include social
distancing frequent hand-washing with
base covering these public health tools
have and will continue to slow the
spread of covered 19 I appreciate
this morning to provide a brief overview
of some of CDC's ongoing work in
response to Co goodnight
CDC has been working 24/7 to combat the
pandemic
CDC's Emergency Operations Center is
supporting state tribal local and
territorial the Gulf partners in
building core capabilities particularly
workforce laboratory and data and
predictive analytics epidemiologists are
conducting surveillance for coab in 19
as well as conducting health system
surveillance community mitigation teams
are providing guidance on infection
control and contact tracing and our
laboratory experts are performing sauron
serological testing to better define the
extent of asymptomatic populations as
local leadership makes decisions to
reopen they'll require varying degrees
of federal support each location will be
different and will face unique
circumstances
CDC has conducted a state-by-state
assessment of public health testing
capacity and key contact tracing
capacity as well as surge plans CDC is
providing technical assistance and
funding to the states provided through
supplemental cares Act in the paycheck
protection program and health care
Enhancement we're working directly with
the state public health leaders to
define their needs for testing and
testing devices supplies and manpower
surveillance data collection and
reporting contact tracing infection
control and outbreak investigation I
want to spend a moment to focus on
several key elements first testing rapid
extensive and widely available timely
testing is essential for reopening
America CDC's role in testing continues
to support diagnosis and contact tracing
surveillance and outbreak we work with
the public health partners to define
their particular testing strategy their
jurisdiction animal drive will address
the testing components of the response
greater detail contact tracing
increasing state tribal local
territorial contact tracing capacity is
critical it's a critical part to stop
the change the transmission and prevent
the occurrence of sustained community
transfer
DTC's role is to provide technical
training assistance and support to the
states as they hire and build a
workforce necessary to be fully prepared
to effectively respond to the public
health challenges posed by the ongoing
coded pandemic this will be an expansive
effort surveillance our nation's
surveillance program is built on a
combination assistance including
existent xisting syndromic influenza and
respiratory viral disease surveillance
systems have been combined with
commercial and research lab platforms
and our case reporting form system EDC
is adapting these and optimizing it to
have a surveillance system in response
to cope in nineteen importantly in light
of the significant occurrence of
asymptomatic infection the surveillance
for asymptomatic infection becomes an
important public health tool early case
identification CDC is working with each
public health jurisdiction to develop a
perspective surveillance program to
include active surveillance among those
that are most vulnerable such as
individuals in long-term care facilities
intercity clinics and homeless shelters
we need to rebuild our nation's public
health infrastructure and in a littlie
Health Laboratory resilience and our
nation's public health workforce now is
the time to put it in place for the
generations to come not only for the
public health system that our nation
needs but for the public health system
our nation deserves
before I close I want to recognize the
tireless commitment the dedicated CDC
staff who deployed every corner of this
nation to fight koban 19 more than 4,000
employees have deployed earing globally
science and data continue with technical
expertise and public source service to
be the backbone of CDC's contributions
to the US response I extend my serious
gratitude to the health care workers in
the frontlines as well as their family
and the essential emergency personnel as
well as the American people to say thank
you for adhering to the stay on home
guidelines and protecting the most
vulnerable it's important to emphasize
that we're not out of the woods yet
battle contends only months but we are
more prepared we need to stay
social distancing it remains an
imperative we are a resilient nation and
I am confident that we will emerge from
this pandemic longer together thank you
thank you dr. Redfield Admiral welcome
here to provide you with an update on
the nation's progress in testing for
kovat 19 on March 12th secretary aids
are requested that I lead the kovat 19
testing efforts within HHS including
oversight and coordination of the FDA
and CDC with regard to testing since
then the nation has performed more than
9 million COBIT 19 tap a number far
greater than any other country and
double the per capita test performed to
date in South Korea to reach this point
we implemented a phased approach to meet
testing needs during mitigation and now
during phase 1 reopening of America
beginning March 20th we pioneered 41
community-based drive-through testing
sites in locations prioritized by the
CDC these sites have been a profound
success testing over 167,000 high-risk
individuals and demonstrating a
prototype that is being duplicated
multifold
in nearly every state next the
administration leveraged trusted
retailers including CVS Rite Aid
Walgreens Walmart Kroger and health Mart
who are now providing testing at 240
locations in 33 states 69% of which are
in communities with moderate to high
social vulnerability to meet the need
for collection supplies like swabs and
media tubes we first secured the global
supply chain through a military air
bridge we worked directly with
manufacturers to increase domestic
production we collaborated with the
private sector and the FDA to validate
multiple swab and media types that
vastly expanded supplies while
minimizing the need for PPE finally we
used title three of the defense
production act to further invest in
domestic manufacturing to prepare us for
reopening to support the need for
surveillance testing during reopening on
April 27th we issued a new testing
framework that also prioritized testing
for persons without symptoms who are
prioritized by health department's or
clinicians for any reason including
screening of asymptomatic individuals
according to state and local plans
next our federal multidisciplinary team
conducted multiple calls with leadership
from each state to set state specific
testing objectives
collectively states and territories
established an overall goal to perform
12.9 million tests over the next four
weeks the federal government is able to
and will support the achievement of this
goal specifically the federal government
is shipping to States twelve point nine
million swabs and over nine point seven
million tubes of media in May alone last
month we also detailed the location and
capacity of every lab machine in every
state that could potentially run kovat
19 assays and our team has worked with
test suppliers to match reagents to
these machines looking forward between
now and the end of 2020 the federal
government will procure over 135 million
swabs and 132 million tubes of media and
distribute these to States as requested
to supplement the now robust commercial
supply we anticipate marked increases in
current tests as well as a dramatic
expansion of new point-of-care tests
like the first in-class quenelle antigen
test authorized by the fda just last
Friday
wadell anticipates being able to
distribute 300,000 tests per day within
just a few weeks so by September taking
every aspect of development
authorization manufacturing and supply
chain into consideration we project that
our nation will be capable of performing
at least 40 to 50 million tests per
month if needed at that time and if new
technologies are authorized like whole
genome sequencing approaches or any
novel solutions uncovered by NIH s new
diagnostics initiative that number will
be much higher finally I want to
acknowledge and express my heartfelt
gratitude to the officers of the US
Public Health Service commissioned Corps
the uniformed service I am honored to
lead 3471 men and women have deployed in
support of the
pandemic on the cruise ship in Japan to
our military bases repatriating American
to our community-based testing sites and
International Airport to FEMA and our
task forces to nursing facilities
including King County Washington and two
field hospitals and hard-hit communities
across our nation I thank each and every
one of these officers and their families
and on their behalf I thank the members
of this committee for supporting our
training needs and the establishment of
already reserved to supplement our ranks
in future national emergencies thank you
for the opportunity to provide these
remarks Thank You Admiral juruá and now
dr. Stephen Hahn
our fourth and final witness chairman
Alexander ranking member marianm members
of the committee thank you for inviting
me to participate in this hearing today
I first want to start by thanking the
American people for their incredible
efforts at mitigation and extend my
condolences to those who have lost loved
ones from day one of this pandemic the
18000 FDA employees are just incredible
scientists doctors and nurses have taken
an active role in the all of government
response to this pandemic FDA has worked
to facilitate the development of medical
countermeasures to diagnose treat and
prevent over nineteen we've worked
closely with laboratories manufacturers
academia product developers our federal
partners and companies companies that
don't even make medical products but
want to pitch in for example by making
hand sanitizer personal protective
equipment and ventilators every decision
we have made have been driven by data
with the goal of protecting the health
of the American people in a public
health emergency however our response
has balanced the urgent need to make
medical products available with the
provision of a level of oversight that
helps ensure the safety and
effectiveness of those medical products
I'd like to take a few minutes to tell
you what FDA is doing to help the
country at this point and which
Marrakesh oath is safe to return to work
in to school it starts with testing
as others have mentioned FDA has worked
with more than 500 developers have or
said they will be submitting emergency
use authorization requests for mobile 19
tests this includes some newer
technologies that not that heretofore
have not been used as part of diagnostic
tests in response to a pandemic we have
issued 92 individual emergency use
authorization for test kit manufacturers
and laboratories and we've been informed
by more than 250 laboratories they begun
testing under the regulatory flexibility
zwi outlined in March we are conducting
rolling reviews of UA submissions so
that we can quickly authorize tests in
which the data support in a public
health emergency the accuracy of
diagnostic tests is important not only
for the individual patient but for the
patient at large for public at large FDA
is helping to ensure the availability of
tests that are providing accurate
answers we are also monitoring the
marketplace for fraudulent tests and are
taking appropriate action to protect the
public health and we are working to
provide more clarity about which tests
have been reviewed and authorized by FDA
and which have not seer logic tests will
play a role in our recovery unlike
diagnostic tests which detect the
presence of the virus serologic test--
measure the amount of antibodies or
protein present in the blood when the
body is responding to an infection like
Kovac 19 these tests can help identify
individuals who can overcome an
infection developed an immune response
we will continue working with labs
manufacturers and across the government
to find a balance between the assurance
that an antibody test is accurate and
timely access to such tests of course
the way we will eventually beat this
virus is with a vaccine an FDA is
working closely with our federal
partners including the NIH tested I mean
vaccine developers manufacturers and
experts across the globe we intend to
use our regulatory flexibility to help
ensure the most ensure efficient
development of a safe and effective
vaccine to prevent kovat 19 until a
preventive vaccine is approved however
we need medical products to bridge the
gap FDA has been working for
months to facilitate the development and
availability of therapeutics as
expeditiously as possible and we created
an emergency program for this
acceleration called the corona treatment
Colonel Myers treatment acceleration
program receipt that we have reassigned
staff to work with urgency to review
requests from companies scientist
doctors who are developing therapies and
we're using every available authority
and register regulatory flexibility
that's appropriate to facilitate the
development of safe and effective
products to treat kovat 19 a variety of
therapeutic areas are being evaluated by
doctors therapists as well as
convalescent Plaza high Permian globulin
and monoclonal antibodies as dr. Fauci
also mentioned we recently announced the
positive results of the NIAID trial a
trend disappear and issued an EU a for
the treatment of hospitalized patients
with Co V 19 two other promising
treatments that I mentioned are the
antibody rich products convalescent
plasma and eye cream globulin and I am
certainly willing to go into more detail
if members of this committee had
question questions about this we are
working very aggressively and closely
with stakeholders to the facilitate the
development of monoclonal antibodies
which if shown to be safe and effective
could act as a bridge therapy to the
development of vaccine we recognize that
developing vaccines and therapies need
to go hand in hand with ensuring that
there will be sufficient supplies for
our companies for our country so we're
also working with manufacturers to make
sure that this supply chain is robust
mr. chairman ranking member members of
the committee please know that an FDA of
a dedicated team of some of the nation's
finest scientists health care providers
and public health professionals we are
guided by science and data and we won't
let up until we facilitate the
development of products that our nation
needs to get back to work I look forward
to your questions
thank you dr. Hahn and thanks to all
four of you for your expertise for your
dedication to our country and your hard
work will now begin around a five-minute
questions from each senator on the
committee
alternating between Republic
Democrats each senator has if you're a
video conference you have a little time
clock at the bottom and I would ask you
to try to stay within 5 minutes for your
questions and answers I will start I've
got a question for dr. ouchy and then
Admiral Sherlock doctor let's look down
the road three months there will be
about 5,000 campuses across the country
trying to welcome 20 million college
students 100,000 public schools
welcoming 50 million students what would
you say to the Chancellor of the
University of Tennessee Knoxville or the
President or the principal of a public
school about how to persuade parents and
students to return the school in August
let's start with treatments and vaccines
first dr. Falchi name you can save about
half of my five minutes for ED ones or
their testing I would appreciate thank
you very much mr. chairman
well I would be very realistic with the
Chancellor and tell him that when we're
thinking in terms it's a hurt in this
case I would tell her I'm sorry sir that
in this case that the idea of having
treatments available or a vaccine to
facilitate the re-entry of students into
the fall term would be something that
would be a bit of a bridge too far as I
mentioned a drug that has shown some
degree of of efficacy was modest and it
was in hospitalized patients not yet or
maybe ever to be used either yet as
prophylaxis or treatment so if the issue
is that the young individuals who'll be
going back to school would like to have
some comfort and that there's a
treatment probably the thing that would
be closest to utilization then would
likely be passive transfer of
convalescent serum but we're really not
talking about necessarily treating a
student who gets ill but how the student
will feel safe and going back to school
if this were a situation where we had a
vaccine
would really be the end of that issue in
a positive way but as I mentioned in my
opening remarks even at the top speed
we're going we don't see a vaccine
playing in the ability of individuals to
get back to school this turn what they
really want is to know if they are safe
and that's the question that have to be
do with what we discussed earlier about
testing so I'm about halfway through the
remarks I'd like to just pass the baton
to Admiral jawad who would address the
question of the availability of testing
and what role that might play in
returning to school thank you sir thank
you thank you doctor Vecchio to Everwood
your why you you said that while we're
doing about 10 million tests this month
that we might be as high as 40 or 50
million by September and and a month
which is a significant increase so if
I'm Chancellor of the University of
Tennessee could I develop a strategy
where I'd say to all my students we have
for example an antigen test which is
quick and easy you want everybody on
campus to come by and take it once
before you begin school that would at
least let everybody know that on that
day we've isolated anybody who's
positive and then we can continue to
monitor is that strategy possible in
August and September so thank you mr.
chairman and I may reserve 20 seconds
for dr. Redfield as well on the strategy
that's going to be employed really
depends heavily on what's the community
spread at that time if there's almost no
community spread your strategy will be
different if there's high community
stress spread it will also be different
but yes technically we will have the
ability and your Chancellor will have
the ability we expect there to be 25 to
30 million point-of-care tests per month
available is certainly possible to test
all of the students or it is much more
likely that there would be a
surveillance strategy done where you may
test some of the students at different
times to give an assurance that there's
no circulation that would be done in
conjunction with the CDC in the local
health department
there's also strategies that are still
needing to be validated but of pooling
samples on we know in some experimental
labs as many as 10 or
samples can be pooled so essentially one
test to test 20 students and finally
there are some experimental progess that
look interesting if not promising that
for example wastewater from an entire
dorm or an entire segment of a campus
could be tested to determine whether
there's coronavirus in that that sewage
the wastewater on so there are other
strategies being developed and I'd like
to at least give 20 seconds to dr.
Redfield who really will be working on
the strategy how to employ this house
given different community Fred dr. edsen
yeah just some quick climate sir I mean
first I think it's really important to
evaluate critically the role of changes
in social distancing on college campuses
and and schools in the situation not to
forget the importance of what we've
learned clearly also developing an
aggressive program for wellness
education making sure people understand
when they're symptomatic they need to
seek evaluation I think you are going to
have to look at the role of testing I
think there is going to be an important
role of testing in this circumstances
and I I think it will be individualized
based on where these different schools
are where they how much infection is in
it I'm going to wrap it up there so I
can set a good example for the other
senators were there five minutes senator
Murray ah thank you very much mr.
chairman and thank you to all of our
witnesses um dr. pouchy you have warned
a needless suffering and death if we
push to reopen too soon but the
president has actually been sending the
opposite message I want to ask you today
what is the most important message you
have for communities and states that are
reopening even as our public health
experts make it clear it's too soon tell
us what the consequences are thank you
very much for that question senator
Murray as I've said many times publicly
what we have worked out is a guideline
framework of how to safely open America
again and there are several checkpoints
of that with a gateway
first of showing depending on the
dynamics
of an outbreak in a particular region
state city or area that would really
determine the speed and the pace with
which one does re-enter or reopen so my
my word has been and I've been very
consistent in this that I get concerned
if you have a situation with the
dynamics of an outbreak in an area as
such that you are not seeing that
gradual of the 14-day decrease that
would allow you to go to phase one and
then if you pass the checkpoints of
phase one go to phase two and phase
three but I've expressed then and again
is my concern that if some areas city
states or what-have-you jump over those
various checkpoints and prematurely open
up without having the capability of
being able to respond effectively and
efficiently my concern is that we will
start to see little spikes that might
turn into outbreaks so therefore I have
been being very clear and my message to
try to the best extent possible to go by
the guidelines which have been very well
thought out and very well delineated so
if a community or a state the
consequences could be pretty dire
correct the consequences could be really
uh serious particularly and this is
something that I think we also should
pay attention to that states even if
they're doing it at an appropriate pace
which many of them are and will namely a
pace that's commensurate with the
dynamics of the outbreak that they have
in place already the capability and when
there will be cases there is no doubt
even under the best of circumstances
when you pull back on mitigation you
will see some cases appear it's the
ability and the capability of responding
to those cases with good identification
isolation and contact tracing will
determine whether you can continue to go
forward as you try to reopen America so
it's not only doing it at the approach
a time but the appropriate constraints
but having in place the capability of
responding when the inevitable return of
infections occur well thank you for that
and it's very clear in order to do that
we need knowledge which is about testing
and for months this administration's
approach to testing has really been
plagued by unrealized schools and
disregard for systemic problems within
that supply chain and last week an
average of just 250,000 tests per day
were performed in the United States that
is a small fraction of what we need and
yesterday President Trump had the gall
to declare the US had quote failed on
testing in a pressed press conference
that was filled with misinformation and
distortions dr. Gerard public health
experts do not think the US has
prevailed I'm glad you finally committed
that states including my home state of
Washington will receive enough tests to
meet their goals for May and June but
this administration has had a record of
giving us broken promises that more
tests and supplies are coming and they
don't and we don't know by the way the
testing is going to needs will persist
long past you know so I wanted to ask
you today will the administration's
forthcoming strategic plan that is now
required under the Kovach package that
was just passed inside into law will
that strategic plan on testing include
specific numeric targets for testing
capacity supply chain capacity and
projection of shortages thank you for
that question and in statement senator
Murray yes we are as I've stated we
continue to have a work in in progress
as we build the testing capacity um we
have established the targets with the
state of over 12 million tests over the
next four weeks we think those targets
are going to be good in May in June but
as dr. Fauci said we really have to be
evidence-based we expect those targets
to go up as we are progressively open as
communities go to phase one and then
into Phase two
and certainly those numbers will need to
go up significantly again in the fall
when we potentially have influenza
circulating with with kovetz so yes
there will be targets the targets will
need to change based on the evidence
that we see but we are highly committed
to securing the supply chain we work
daily with every manufacturer and I'm
just pleased we're in May and June able
to get ahead of the states so that we
can supply them what they need so they
have those assurances there's going to
be any doubts about that to you is when
you put out that specific plan that you
were required to do we will see numbers
that you are going to tell us that you
will reach targeted for testing and
supply chain capacity and production of
sorts
instead of just saying we hope to have a
million this week next week so you will
give us the specific targets correct we
know specifically I'll say yes ma'am we
know the specific we know the specific
amounts of tests we have over the over
the summer we are how many we need
so yes ma'am
we developed the need statements by
working with the states individually
with epidemiologists with the CDC so
that overall in May will be testing
about 3.9 percent of the overall US
population how many will need not just
for me but in the coming months so that
we can be prepared to have them yes
ma'am in and not to be repetitive but um
we need to be evidence and data-driven
because what what we may see in May or
June will drive differences in the
amount of test goals we have so we we
really just need to be very humble about
this we need to look at the data we know
that the testing needs will go up over
May and June as we progressively open
and we will do our best to predict that
but you have to understand we have to
see what the data and the evidence show
at that time okay I appreciate that mr.
chairman again what our strategic plan
requires is what is the goal not how
many we have but how many we need and
that's what we'll be looking for thank
you thank you senator Murray senator
Enzi thank you mister
chairman and I particularly appreciated
your opening statement where you had a
very succinct list of preparations we
need to learn from this endemic for the
next one not only should we be working
on this and preparing but we and I think
we've learned a lot we're fighting a
virus at the same time that scientists
are learning about it so we need to be
nimble we also need to be sure that we
are prepared for a second wave of
outbreaks could coincide with the start
of the flu season potentially stressing
our healthcare system even more than it
already has been
Admiral DRA I thank you for your
comments I think they've been I'm
putting about what has been done and
what can be done I agree with Senator
Murray that we need to have some
specific goals as an accountant that's
always one of the things that I'm
looking for for questions doctor dr.
Hahn our understanding of the clinical
picture of Oban 19 continues to evolve
what first looked like a respiratory
illness now seems much more
comprehensive potentially affecting the
art the brain the kidneys and other
organs how does this evolving picture
impact the ability to evaluate
appropriate clinical or surrogate
endpoints for review of vaccines and
treatment
Thank You senator for that question the
the evolving clinical picture and
obviously the way this is manifesting
around the country clinically does in
fact inform the endpoints that we will
work with developers of therapies on so
that we can get the absolute most
efficient but also the most accurate
information inappropriate end points to
make the necessary authorizations and
approvals we have set up this program
called the corona virus treatment
acceleration program where our top
scientists and clinicians have been at
the table consulting with our colleagues
at NIH and CDC to actually address those
questions what are the appropriate end
points I'll give you an example we do
know that in some circumstances patients
who have had severe Kobe disease have
developed thrombotic for clotting type
episodes and so we prioritize a review
of agents that we think might be
beneficial and obviously the clinical
endpoints for those trials will be
different than an agent that's an
antiviral like Brenda severe where as
dr. Fauci mentioned we're looking at
time to recovery so we want to adapt it
to the clinical circumstance as well as
to the type of therapy that's put before
us thank you
another question to dr. Han we have made
a lot of progress in vaccine development
but Barda has identified that domestic
manufacturing of needles and syringes is
a significant gap in pandemic
preparedness
what has HHS done in advance eventual
national campaign to ensure that we have
sufficient has to be administered a
vaccine Cindy thank you for that
question this is a really important
point because it's not just about the
vaccine or hopefully vaccines that are
developed it's all about it's also about
the supplies that are needed as well as
an operational plan for administering
the vaccine so this is an all of
government approach there is a program
that's been set up called Operation
warp-speed that includes dr. Collins dr.
Fauci his colleagues at NIH the
Department of Defense as well as other
members of HHS and FDA dr. Pierre marks
from our Center for Biological
evaluation research has been helping
coordinate that is working very closely
with dr. Fauci and his team and we've
created what's called a Gantt chart to
look forward what are the necessary
supply chain issues syringes needles etc
depending on the various vaccines that
are being developed how many times they
have to administer and the route of
administration so we've been leaning in
on this supply chain to ensure that when
a vaccine is ready to go we will have
the necessary supplies to actually
administer it and operationalize the
vaccination thank you
I have a couple more questions but again
the clocks not visible there I'll submit
those in writing Thank You senator Enzi
senator Sanders thank you very much mr.
chairman
and let me thank all of the panelists
for the hard work they are doing and for
being with us today
it is sad to say that we have a
President of the United States the
leader of our country who from day one
downplayed the dangers facing this
country from the pandemic who told us
that the crisis would be over in a few
months that we did not have to worry who
fired those members of the government
who wanted to act aggressively in among
other things their time when we need
international cooperation cut funding
for the World Health Organization but
let me also say that I think we
understand that facts are terribly
important not everybody that we don't
fully understand all of the
ramifications of the kovat 19 epidemic
but let me a spot the facts a few
questions if I might for a thought the
official statistic dr. pouchy is that
80,000 Americans had died from the
pandemic there are some epidemiologist
who suggests the number may be 50%
higher than that what do you think I'm
not sure senator Sanders if it's gonna
be 50% higher but most of us feel that
the number of deaths are likely higher
than that number because given the
situation particularly in New York City
when they were really strapped with a
very serious challenge to their health
care system that there may have been
people who died at home who did have
some ovid who are not counted as Colvin
because they never really got to the
hospital so in direct answer to your
question I think you are correct
at the number is likely higher I don't
know exactly what was that tire but
almost certainly it's higher doctor
Falchi let me ask you this in the
terrible pandemic of 1918 the virus
exploded in the fall it came back with a
vengeance are we fearful that if we
don't get our act together as bad as the
situation is now it could become worse
in the fall or winter Oh senator thank
you for that question it's a frequently
asked question and I think that a
possibility does exist however and the
reason I say that is that when you talk
about will this virus just disappear and
as I said publicly many times that is
just not gonna happen because it's such
a highly transmissible virus and even if
we get better control over the summer
months it is likely that there will be
virus somewhere in this on this planet
that will eventually get back to us so
my approach towards the possibility of a
rebound and a second wave of the fall is
that a it's entirely conceivable and
possible that it would happen but B I
would hope that between now and then
given the capability of doing the
testing that you've heard from Raja hua
and the ability of us to stock up on
personal protective equipment and the
workforce that the CDC under dr.
Redfield will be putting forth to be
able to identify isolated contact trace
I hope that if we do have the threat of
a second wave we will be able to deal
with it very effectively to prevent it
from becoming an outbreak not only worse
than now but much much less okay let me
ask we've heard a lot of discussion
about vaccines obviously everybody in
Congress and in this country wants a
vaccine we wanted as quickly as possible
as effective as possible oh let me ask
the Honorable FDA Commissioner sir if
God
willing a vaccine is developed and if
we're able to produce it as quickly as
we all hope we can I would imagine that
that vaccine would be distributed to all
people a free of charge we'll make sure
at least at everybody in America who
needs that vaccine we'll get it
regardless of their income is that a
fair assumption
senator IgE I certainly hope so
FDA is very committed to making sure
that all populations in the United
States including those most vulnerable
are included in the clinical trials and
one out there that's not what I'm asking
what I'm asking is if and when the
vaccine comes it won't do somebody any
good if they don't get it and if they
have to pay a sum of money for it
in order to profit the drug companies
that will not be helpful are you
guaranteeing the American people today
that that vaccine will be available to
all people regardless of their income
sure the payment of vaccines is not a
responsibility of FDA but the task force
I share your concern that this needs to
be made available to every American does
anybody else want to comment on that mr.
Tory
we should make that vaccine when
hopefully it is created available to all
regardless of income what do you think
that poor people working people should
be less than line for the vaccine I'm
sorry senator were you asking me yes i
won sir yes I was no I I my office is
one of the offices committed to serving
the underserved and we need to be
absolutely certain that if a vaccine or
an effective therapeutic or preventive
is available that it reaches all
segments of society regardless of their
ability to pay or any other social
determinants of health that there may be
good so when you are telling the
American people today that regardless of
income every American will be able to
gain access to that vaccine when it
comes
they should have gained access to it I
don't control you know I think you
represent you represent an
administration that makes that decision
I will certainly advocate that everyone
is able to receive the vaccine
regardless of income or any other
circumstance
let me just say I'm sorry all right
Thank You mr. chair
those are important questions that I
don't want to catch senators up but and
it's hard to see the the the time clock
whether we could stay as close as
possible five minutes then all senators
can get their questions in Thank You
senator Sanders senator burr Thank You
mr. chairman and thank our witnesses
today for what you've done for the
people in this country and their safety
and people around the globe let me ask
you dr. Falchi because you've been in
the task force and at a majority of the
press conferences has anybody in this
administration ever asked you or any
member to take the foot off the gas of
trying to find a cure or or any type of
countermeasure no senator not at all as
a matter of fact we at NIH as you know
haven't been right from the very
beginning put off foot right on that
accelerator in every aspect including
the development of vaccines and
therapeutics and as I described my
opening statement we actually
that in January literally days after
virus was known in its sequence was
published so no I have never been
followed by anyone to hold back on the
development of any countermeasure
or any basic and research project that
we've been involved in thank you doctor
Falchi this question is for dr. Redfield
dr. Redfield we have authorized in this
committee and appropriated out of
Congress multiple times over the last
few decades money for virus severe
biosurveillance and you talked about it
in the past of 20 years from FY 16 to 20
it's been twenty three million dollars a
year and with the cures Act it's over a
billion dollars in biosurveillance we've
seen the private sector go out and use
data available to track the progress and
spread of coronavirus around the world
why is CDC not contracted with private
sector technology companies to try to
use their tools for bio surveillance
senator thank you for the question this
is a critical issue as you know and it
also comes into one of the core
capabilities I talked about data
analytics and data modernization which
we're appreciative of the additional
funding Congress has given I can tell
you that this is under a critical review
now we do have contracts with some of
the private sector groups now to try to
make the type of availability of data
that we've seen with Florida available
in all of our jurisdictions across the
country and and in the process of making
that happen dr. Redfield in April of
last year
a june of last year we reauthorized the
pandemic and all-hazards legislation
which authorized at that time 30 new
billets 30 new employees at CDC
specifically in surveillance now I asked
dr. shewket in March how many of those
30 had been filled
she said zero as of mid-april zero of
those 30 billets had been filled how
many of those 30 employees that this
committee authorized CDC to bring
for biosurveillance have been filled
today sir again thank you for the
question I know our staffs have been in
discussion since dr. Schaack it's a
testimony and I know we're in the
process of continuing to try to figure
out how to move that forward sir
I can get back to you on it as I discuss
what progress has been made since we had
that discussion poster we're hearing
with you when you brought that delight
well I brought it to light the first
March and now we're in mid-may so I'm
hopeful that we won't just talk about
surveillance will actually execute it
and we'll focus the unbelievable amounts
of money that we've provided for you
that they will show some some benefit to
the American people dr. pouchy let me
come back to you this is one of the
fastest development timelines we've ever
seen for vaccines and the American
people and hopefully people around the
world will be the beneficiary of what
you what you find and the eventual
licensure of that product what are the
biggest unknowns with this particular
virus that can affect the development
process and dr. Hahn if you've got
anything to add after that to this
please do dr. pouchy yeah thank you very
much senator burr well there are a
couple of things that I think are
inherent in all vaccine development
first of all there's no guarantee that
the vaccine is actually going to be
effective as you well know because we've
discussed this many times in the past
and you can have everything you think
that's in place and you don't induce the
kind of immune response that turns out
to be protective and durably protected
so one the big unknown is it will be
effective given the way the body
responds to viruses of this type I'm
cautiously optimistic that we will with
one of the candidates get an efficacy
signal the other thing that's an unknown
that's of concern we'll be able to get
around that by doing the tests properly
is that do you get an enhancement effect
namely there have been a number of
vaccines to in particular dengue and
respiratory syncytial virus when the
vaccine induced
a suboptimal response and when a person
gets exposed they actually have an
enhanced pathogenesis of the disease
which is always worry since we want to
make sure that that doesn't happen those
are the two major unknowns putting all
those things together senator Byrd
I still feel cautiously optimistic that
we will have a candidate that will give
some degree of efficacy hopefully a
percentage enough that will induce the
kind of herd immunity that would give a
protection to the population at home dr.
Hahn anything to add to that yes sir
thank you for the question the obstacle
is from a regulatory point of view
um I think are being met by the the
approach that's being taken out of HHS
and led by Peter marks and that is a
common preclinical development pathway
so that we can appropriately assess one
vaccine against the other and then a
master protocol that allows for a common
control group and an assessment to very
common endpoints that'll let us be as
efficient as possible for the
development of vaccine a we will
evaluate approximately ten candidates
pre clinically and then in the phase 1
and phase 2 studies and then takes 4 to
5 into phase 3 studies in this HHS
effort so I think those are the
obstacles that can be broken down to
speed the development but also allow us
to ensure safety and effectiveness mr.
chairman yesterday the state of North
Carolina started to publicize the
recovered numbers those individuals who
have had corona the virus but have
recovered it's my hope that nationally
we will start reporting the recovered
numbers I think that's important for the
American people to hear I yield back
thank you senator burr senator Casey mr.
chairman thank you for the hearing as
well as ranking members Murray mr.
chairman I wanted to start today with a
question regarding nursing homes in
particular across the state like ours
we've had as you might know a high
number of cases in Pennsylvania
at last count over 57,000 cases the
number of deaths have gone above 3700
and of course a lot of those deaths are
in
nursing-homes we're told that nationally
more than a third as high as 35 percent
of all deaths have been in nursing homes
either the death of a resident of a
nursing home or a worker I want to start
with today with a question for dr.
Redfield doctor when when we consider
this challenge in our in our long-term
care facilities when we look at the
number of deaths and nursing homes I
think a lot of families want basic
transparency and that's one of the
reasons why Senator Wyden and I sent you
a letter dated April the 2nd it was
directed to you as well as the
administrator of the Centers on Medicare
Medicaid Services Seema Verma
and in that letter we asked for basic
information about what the
administration was doing to track the
outbreaks and nursing homes to provide
information basic information to
families in their in and residents the
families of residents in nursing homes
currently to the workers as well as to
the community and public health
professionals now it took you over about
a month to respond to that but in your
response you didn't give us any
information about the timeline these
families eat this information and now
we're told by the CMS administrator
after pressing errors senator Wyden and
I did that this information may not be
available until the end of May I need to
hear from you today why is there been a
delay a three-month delay and basic
information that families and and people
in it within a community need about the
outbreaks in nursing homes the number of
cases what is happening in nursing homes
tell us when we're going to see that
information well thank you very much
senator and you've highlighted one of
the great tragedies that we've all
experienced together clearly
long-term care facilities have been
particularly hard hit by this pandemic
several things I know that again mess
who has oversight several things have
been done and I can get back to you in
terms of where they're at in terms of
activation but clearly all nursing homes
now are required to report cases in
either their individuals that are
patients there or at our staff to the
CDC um secondly I have to put a policy
in place that all nursing homes are
required to notify members of that
nursing home of the existence of Ovid in
that nursing home include family members
verify in terms of when that's if that's
operational today or last week and I
will get back to you with that one of
the most important we have to do as we
talk about key and reopening as Tony
mentioned we need it's symptomatic cases
we need to be do tack tracing but the
other thing that we really need to do is
to do surveillance because this virus
does appear to have a high propensity
for it's symptomatic infection which
means for traditional ways of defying
cases is going to be blunted and so
we're developing a national surveillance
system and first important is to do a
comprehensive surveillance in all the
nursing states CDC will be doing that in
partnership with the state and local
territorial health departments
I think cursor is gonna have the
responsibility to do it within the
inner-city clinics that are selected in
Annie and health service for the Indian
Health Service clinics but this is
critical you get in front of this and do
comprehensive surveillance of everybody
in these nursing homes we've also done
you know aggressive outreach in all of
them and in enhancing infection control
procedures etc CDC has been out
yeah help these nursing homes with that
into the guidance along with this um but
I'll get back to you in terms of the
time I'm pretty confident they're
already it's like the operational but I
need to double check is to make sure
because I know Seema has announced that
they're all reporting to CDC that any
infection in workers or patients and
that they are required now to notify
other members in the nursing home as
well as family members of that um when
it is in one of those I did mr. chairman
just have one question for dr. foxy
doctor I wanted to ask you in your
testimony earlier in response to a
question by Senator Murray you outlined
a basic concern you have with regard to
states reopening can you restate that
for us yes thank you senator Casey yes
my concern is that if states or cities
or regions their attempt understandable
to get back to some form of normality
disregard to a greater or lesser degree
the checkpoints that we put in our
guidelines but when it is safety seed
and pulling back on mitigation because I
feel if that occurs there is a real risk
that you will trigger an outbreak as you
may not be able to control which in fact
paradoxically will set you back not only
leading to some suffering and death it
could be avoided but could even set you
back on the road to trying to get
economic recovery but it would almost
turn the clock back rather than going
forward that is my major concern son
thank you thank you doctor mr. chairman
Thank You senator Casey Senator Paul dr.
Falchi Sen scientists have shown that
rhesus monkeys that are infected with
kovat 19 cannot be reinfected several
studies have also shown that plasma from
recently infected coronavirus patients
neutralizes the virus and lab
experiments in addition infusion of
convalescent plasmas based on the idea
that recovering coronavirus patients are
developing amenity and that it can be
beneficial as
studies show that the recovering kovat
19 patients from the asymptomatic to the
very sick are showing significant
antibody response
studies show that SARS and MERS also
quota viruses induce immunity for at
least two to three years and yet the
media continues to report that we have
no evidence that patients who survived
coronavirus have immunity I think
actually the truth is the opposite we
have no evidence that survivors of
coronavirus don't have immunity and a
great deal of evidence to suggest that
they do the question of immunity is
linked to health policy and that workers
who have gained immunity can be a strong
part of our economic recovery the silver
lining to so many infections in the meat
processing industry is that a large
portion of these workers now have
immunity those workers should be
reassured that they likely won't get it
again instead of being alarmed by media
reports that there is no evidence of
immunity you've stated publicly that
you'd bet at all that survivors of
coronavirus have some form of immunity
can you help set the record straight
that the scientific record as it's being
accumulated is supportive that infection
with coronavirus likely leads to some
form of immunity
dr. Falchi yep thank you for the
question Senator Paul yes you're correct
that I have said that given what we know
about the recovery from viruses such as
corona viruses in general or even any
infectious disease with very few
exceptions that when you have anybody
present it is very likely indicates a
degree of protection I think it's in the
semantics of how this is expressed when
you say has it been formally proven by
long-term natural history studies which
is the only way that you can prove one
is it protective which I said and would
repeat is likely that it is but also
what is the degree or titer of antibody
that gives you that critical level of
protection and what is the durability as
I've often said you may again repeat you
can make a reasonable assumption that it
would be protective but natural history
studies over a period of months two
years but then tell you definitively is
that
the case and I think that's important
because in all likelihood is a good way
of putting it the vast majority of these
people have immunity instead of saying
there is no evidence
you know the w-h-o kind of fed into this
by saying no evidence of immunity and in
reality there's every evidence stacking
up and in fact a lot of the different
studies have shown that it is very
unlikely to get it again in the
short-term with regard to going back to
school
one thing that was left out of that
discussion is mortality I mean shouldn't
we at least be discussing what the
mortality of children is this is for dr.
Falchi as well you know the mortality
between 0 and 18 in the New York data
approaches zero it's not gonna be
absolutely zero but it almost approaches
zero between 18 and 45 the mortality in
New York was ten out of a hundred
thousand so really we do need to be
thinking about that we need to observe
with an open mind what went on in Sweden
where the kids kept going to school the
mortality per capita in Sweden is
actually less than France less than
Italy less in Spain less than Belgium
less than the Netherlands about the same
as Switzerland but basically I don't
think there's anybody arguing that what
happened in Sweden is an unacceptable
result I think people are intrigued by
it and we should be I don't think any of
us are certain when we do all these
modeling's there have been more people
wrong with modelling than right we're
opening up a lot of economies around the
around the u.s. and I hope that people
who are predicting doom and gloom and
saying oh we can't do this is going to
be the surge we'll admit that they were
wrong if there isn't a surge because I
think that's what's going to happen in
rural states we never really reached any
sort of pandemic levels in Kentucky and
other states we have less deaths in
Kentucky than we have in us in and an
average flu season it's not to say this
isn't deadly but really outside of New
England we've had a relatively benign
course for this virus nationwide and I
think the one size fits all that we're
gonna have a national strategy and
nobody's gonna go to school is kind of
ridiculous we really ought to be doing
at school district by school district
and the power needs to be dispersed
because people make wrong predictions
and really the history of this when we
look back will be of wrong prediction
after wrong prediction after wrong
prediction starting with Fergus
in England so I think we ought to have a
little bit of humility in our belief
that we know what's best for the economy
and as much as I respect you dr. Falchi
I don't think you're the end-all I don't
think you're the one person that gets to
make a decision we can listen to your
advice but there are people on the other
side saying there's not going to be a
surge and that we can safely open the
economy and the facts will to bear this
out but if we keep kids out of school
for another year what's gonna happen is
the poor and underprivileged kids who
don't have a parent that's able to teach
them at home are not gonna learn for a
full year and I think we got to look at
the Swedish model and we ought to look
at letting our kids get back to school I
think it's a huge mistake if we don't
open the schools in the fall thank you
mr. chairman could I respond to that
even though they're only 32 seconds left
yes and you might make it clear whether
or not you suggested that
we shouldn't go back to school in the
fall well first of all Senator Paul
thank you for your comments I have never
made myself out to be the end-all and
only voice of this I'm a scientist a
physician and a public health official I
give advice according to the best
scientific evidence there are a number
of other people who come into that and
give advice that are more related to the
things that you spoke about about the
need to get the country back open again
and economically I don't give advice
about economic things I don't get advice
about anything other than public health
so I wanted to respond to that the
second thing is that you use the word we
should be humble about what we don't
know and I think that falls under the
fact that we don't know everything about
this virus and we really better be very
careful particularly when it comes to
children because the more and more we
learn we're seeing things about what
this virus can do that we didn't see
from the studies in China or in Europe
brigs sample right now children
presenting with Kovan 16 window covered
19 who actually have a very strange
inflammatory syndrome very similar to
cover sakis syndrome I think we better
be careful if we are not Cavalier in
thinking that children are completely
immune the deleterious effects so again
you're right in the numbers that
children in general do much much better
than adults and the elderly and
particularly those with other line
conditions but I am very careful and
hopefully humble and knowing that I
don't know everything about this disease
and that's why I'm very reserved in
making broad predictions
thank you thank you Senator Paul and
Senator Baldwin Thank You mr. chairman
and ranking member Murray and our
witnesses I want to cover a lot of
territory in my five minutes so I'd
certainly be appreciative of concise
answers but I want to start with dr.
Redfield direct field I think that the
testing protocols at the White House
presents a model for other essential
workplaces I'm sorry senator you broke
up at the beginning your question if you
could just say it again I'm sorry yes
dr. Redfield do you think that the
testing protocols currently in place in
the White House present a model for
other essential workplaces well I think
well thank you for the question I think
one of the important things you bring up
is the essential worker guidance that
CDC put out and I think it was
originally modeled obviously on health
care workers where there were
significant health care shortages
individuals that works any workplaces
I'm asking if you think that the White
House protocols testing are a model for
other essential workplaces I I would
just say that I think each workplace has
to define their own approach that's how
to operationalize our had some
considerable comment on the fact that
OSHA has not stood up an enforceable
mandatory emergency temporary standard
for workers in all sorts of work
settings but that aside would you say
that the PPE rules and protocols in
effect right now in the White House are
a model for other essential workplaces
we would my own view and would go back
to the guidelines that CDC has put out
about
to work places for people if they are an
essential workforce that they go in
public they maintain six feet distancing
and they wear face coverings okay jawar
you have testified about how far you
come with regard to testing assessments
I want to ask you if you believe that we
already have a national testing strategy
today that spans that spans from the
nationwide testing needs assessment to
the nationwide testing supply assessment
and a strategy to fill that gap to
prepare domestically
what we need in terms of bridging that
gap with testing platforms swabs
specimen collection media and reagents
and the PPE needed to conduct those
tests so thank you for that we do have a
strategy that spans us at least to the
at least to the fall on and beyond as I
mentioned we're working individually
with every state and I think Senator
Paul is correct that Kentucky Wyoming or
New Jersey Rhode Island are different
and there there are vastly different
testing needs the East Coast will have
multiples of testing versus other states
and we're working those individually so
so I know you testified earlier that not
only are you working with the states but
you're working with every lab in every
state to increase capacity what about
working with those who would be the
those who would need testing to say
reopen their school their University
their business
each of them have identified what they
think are their testing needs based on
you know guidance not mandatory
enforceable rules but are you in contact
at that level is your dashboard have
visibility at that lowest level or
mostly in contact with the states and
with the labs so over the last few
months we've done a lot of the
individual work at nursing homes at
meatpacking plants that other I mean
really down to the very granular level
where we are right now however is we are
really working with the state leadership
with the public health lab the state
epidemiologist the shows the state
health officials on because they they
really need to understand what their
some is going to be in their state and
then in the fund and in the funding
we're asking very specifically in the
CDC funding for specific plans for
schools nursing homes underserved
etcetera so I have two more points that
I'm going to make I don't have time for
questions one is about the transparency
of that needs assessment and the public
see it can the state see it can the help
committee members see it is it publicly
available and secondly the delivery of
this supply is a critical issue and it
seems to me that the logistics are
getting this out whether it's PPE
testing or medical equipment is still
extremely fragmented leading to price
gouging and many other inefficiencies we
need to stand up the full power of the
defense production act would you like me
to comment on that ma'am I'm sorry I'm
happy to have you comment it with the
indulgence of the Chairman we've gone
over time and a succinct answer to the
senator please a sad wonder why yes
ma'am and yes sir particularly for
things like swabs and media there is
still a very I would say non mature
industry within the country and that's
why we've we've made the decision to
procure that all centrally through
December and then distribute that to the
state because they're just too many
small companies too many too many
variables to control without a really
heavy federal hand that's just an
example of where we really moved into
that and use the DPA force while
to help support American industry in
more mature aspects of the industry like
some of the large test producers we feel
that by helping direct them to make sure
that the states get what they needed the
right distribution that we're not
procuring them directly by us but again
we're going to be very evidence and
data-driven as we move on thank you sir
thank you very much senator Baldwin
senator Collins Thank You mr. chairman
let me begin by first thanking each of
our witnesses today for their expertise
their dedication and their hard work dr.
Redfield I want to start with you I am
hearing from Dennis
all over the state of Maine that the
fact that they cannot practice in our
two state despite following very strict
infection control protocols is causing
growing health problems Dennis tell me
that teeth with cavities that could have
been filled are now going to need root
canals teeth that could have been
treated with root canals are now going
to require extractions people with oral
cancers cannot get the treatment the
cleanings that they need before
beginning their treatment dental health
is clearly so important and Maine state
officials as well as our dentists are
seeking assistance in reaching the right
decisions 47 other states either have
reopened dental practices or have a data
center for them to reopen so my question
to you is this if dentists are following
the American Dental Association
guidelines if they're instituting strict
protective measures for their patients
their staffs their hygienists
themselves and if their closely
examining and seeing a decline in the
number of kovat 19 infections in their
County are these reasonable factors for
states to consider in reopening the
practice of Dentistry yes senator thank
you for the question you know we've been
interacting and talking with dentist and
working with the state and local public
health officials to update our
guidelines on reopening a variety of
medical services as you know and I think
you raise a very important point and I
would would not disagree with what you
said about looking at the American
Dental Association's as well as the
reality of the outbreak in the area but
we are in the process of updating those
died lines and they will include direct
guidelines for dental practices thank
you very much dr. dr. Jorah and dr. Hahn
recently there's been a significant man
for REM REM does safar I may be
mispronouncing it which transition to
receiving an emergency use authorization
last week Maine's two largest hospital
systems contacted me with questions
about how this therapeutic will be
allocated going forward HHS finally
released a statement on Saturday about
allocations going to States
interestingly not directly to hospitals
but once again the decision making
behind these allocations is very unclear
HHS and the assistant secretary for
preparedness and response say that each
state is expected to receive an
allocation but no timetable has
been provided beyond those who are being
treated with this drug at Maine Medical
Center through a clinical trial
I'm concerned that hospitalized patients
in Maine will have little or no ability
to be treated with this promising
therapeutic for the foreseeable future
as this and more therapeutics and
ultimately a vaccine come on to the
marketplace how can these allocation and
distribution issues be resolved so that
patient care is not delayed and so that
it doesn't depend on which state you
live in whether or not you're going to
get access to these treatments and
ultimately a vaccine Senator Collins
this good Adams wrong go ahead
commissioner
senator Collins I think we completely
agree with you that this has to be an
evidence-based approach getting the
medical therapeutics vaccines from deser
bier whichever it happens to be the
people in need I think we can all agree
upon the fact that we've learned a lot
of lessons from your situation and of
course as you mentioned that's being led
by HHS and I'm an ass for what you've
seen in the most recent announcement is
that what the task force did was provide
guidance to HHS regarding where the most
significant outbreak of hospitalization
outbreak occurred and where those
hospitalization hospitalized patients
were this represented about a quarter of
the supply of drug that we have and more
will be allocated according to
methodology that gets drug to wear those
hospitalized patients are I think
valuable lessons can be learned and will
be learned with respect to other
therapies and to vaccines in particular
and we must incorporate those into our
operational plans moving forward thank
you doctor
Admiral do you have anything tat I'm
overtime sorry thank you if you have
anything to add if you do so for the
record no ma'am no ma'am I agree with
the commissioner
it's it's absolutely critical that it's
evidence-based based on the people who
could benefit from it and also fair and
just throughout our country
dang Thank You Collins and Senator
Murphy I thank you very much mr.
chairman thank you to you and Senator
Murray for convening this thank you to
all of our witnesses for your service
this is obviously an exceptional hearing
today and that three of our witnesses
are in quarantine and so I just want to
start by asking a pretty simple
yes-or-no question that I think I know
the answer to
dr. Fauci dr. Hahn dr. Redfield I'm
correct that all of you are drawing a
salary as you should during your period
of quarantine is that correct
senator let me just let me start off I
think we better be careful about the
issue of quarantine we are essential
work is this part of the essential
infrastructure and we are when needed
which is often who our duties and
respective places at the White House I
was at the White House yesterday and I
will likely even perhaps even be there
today and in my office at the NIH so it
is not really strictly speaking the
quarantine as we know it but it is
performing on duties as critical workers
and I'd be happy to have my colleagues
also respond to that Senator Murphy this
is Steve Hahn I agree with dr. Falchi
yes I am drawing salary and I have
continued to work during my quarantine
and as an essential worker will
participate in meetings face to face
when that attendance is considered
critical my point here listen you all
should draw a salary well you are taking
precautionary steps because of the
contacts you have made my point is that
quarantine is relatively easy for people
like you and me
we can still work and get paid we
telework but there are millions of other
Americans who work jobs that can't be
performed from home or are paid by the
hour and it's just remarkable to me that
this administration has not yet
developed a mechanism for states to
implement and pay for a quarantine
system that will work for all Americans
your plan to reopen America requires
States develop that plan and yet my
state has no clue how to implement and
pay for that system without help from
the federal government which leads me to
my second question dr. vouching dr.
Redfield you've made news today by
warning us appropriately of the dangers
of States opening too early but as
Senator Murray mentioned this is
infuriating to many of us because it
comes hours after the president declared
that we have prevailed over coronavirus
which I'm just going to tell you is
going to make it much harder on state
leaders to keep social distancing
restrictions in place it comes days
after the president called on citizens
to liberate their states from social
distancing orders and I think you're all
noble public servants but I worry that
you're trying to have it both ways
you say this state shouldn't open too
early but then you don't give us the
resources to succeed you work for a
president who is frankly undermining our
efforts to comply with the guidance that
you've given us and then the guidance
that you have provided is criminally
vague and I want to ask my last question
on this topic um obviously the plan to
reopen America was meant to be followed
by more detailed nuanced guidance right
what is a downward trajectory
mean what happens if the trajectory is
downward in some settings but upward in
others what happens if you reopen and
then there's a spike in one location or
another setting and of course you knew
this because you developed this guidance
this this additional guidance that is
site-specific that frankly is helpful
some of this is on the CDC website but
some of it is not and
my state needs it we don't have all of
the experts that you have um and so we
rely on you so reporting suggests dr.
Redfield that this guidance that was
developed by you and other experts was
shelved by the administration that it
was withheld from States in the public
because of a decision made by the White
House so my specific question is why
didn't this plan get released and if it
is just being reviewed when is it going
to be released because states are
reopening right now and we need this
additional guidance to make those
decisions senator I appreciate your
question clearly we have generated a
series of guidances as you know and is
this outbreak response has evolved from
a CDC to an all of government response
as we work through the guidance is a
number of them go for interagency review
and in every agency input to make sure
that these guidances are more broadly
applicable for different parts of our
society the guidance is that you've
talked about have gone through that
inter agents review their comments that
have come back to CDC and I anticipate
they'll go back up into the task force
for final review but we're reopening in
Connecticut in five days in ten days I
mean this guidance isn't going to be
useful to us in two weeks so is it this
week is it next week when are we gonna
get this expertise from the federal
government the other thing I will just
say is that the CDC stands by to give
technical assistance your state in any
state uh upon any request I do
anticipate these broader guidance though
to be posted on the CDC website that
soon I can't tell you so but in I can
tell you your state can reach out to CDC
and will give guidance directly to
anyone on your state on any circumstance
that your state desires guidance from
soon isn't terribly helpful Thank You
mr. chairman thank you senator Murphy
senator Cassidy hey gentlemen thank you
very much for your service and I
a set of questions so if your questions
can be brief I appreciate your answers
can be brief dr. Han in your testimony
you mentioned that the testing for the
populations and the vaccine trials now
includes over Americans I guess my
question though is what about children
does it include children does it also
include the obese the diabetic the
immunocompromised those who are at risk
of having a less non-response or
mitigated response to vaccination can
you comment on that please yes sir
thank you senator Cassidy when the phase
2 phase 3 trials are in place they will
include our most vulnerable populations
including the individuals that you
described we're working very closely so
that I can interrupt phase 2 is normally
checked for safety you would not have to
do a separate phase 2 and the patient
who was younger if I'm senator can you
just assume the safety data from the
adults applies to that of the children
so no we we would also want to assess
safety sir as well in children so the
current phase 2 trials do they include
children they're in phase 1 studies
right now sir you said we had a phase 2
going on well I think it's about to
start from the modernity perhaps dr.
Thatcher you can answer that yeah I know
senator Cassidy's no I know I did not
say a phase 2 is I said we are in a
second dose of the phase 1 and we will
proceed when we finish with phase 1 to
go into phase 2 so I think I'm hearing
that children will be included in phase
2 trials No so that's under discussion
between FDA and NIH at this time sir
because we do realize that it's
important for us to understand what the
seasoned children but that's dr.
Redfield the build back upon 100 murphy
said the published guidelines for
schools at school opening obviously
you're about to modify but I noticed as
I read through them there's nothing
about testing so we speak about testing
targeted testing how we use testing but
the guidelines for the school systems
has nothing about how to integrate
testing will these be in those
guidelines that are being released
senator thanks for the question
clearly there's good need to be has
already been stated an integration of a
testing strategy that is going to be
different for different school settings
as well as different jurisdictions
whether setting and that is going to
have to be integrated into each of those
there's a general overarching guidelines
and then as I say I do think detecting
strategy which is important is including
the surveillance strategy needs to be a
individualized I mean let me come to
that dr. headlines dr. Redfield in all
due respect I think children whether
you're a rural frontier suburban or
urban is the one setting in which there
is a remarkable commonality and and I
will echo what senator Murphy said the
resources that the federal government
has greatly exceeds all but the most
sophisticated populous wealthy state and
even then it exceeds it by some extent
so I do think it would be good to have
okay in a primary school setting
this is best practices or these are
three options and choose between one of
these three to say to each school
district or each private or parochial or
independent school work with your State
Board of Health figure it out seems a
wasted effort I say that because
children play such a role in both
protection of disease the spread of
disease etc so your thoughts on that
because it really seems that's the one
setting where you can have you know not
cookie cutter but certainly a pattern
which can be followed the senator I must
have been misunderstood when I was
talking about differences I was thinking
of the difference between an elementary
school a high school of college in terms
of how we a trade school there may be
differences in how you integrate a
testing strategy but I do think having a
testing strategy with different options
for people to evaluate based on
different principles will be important
in terms of guidance dr. Falchi you
persuasively argue that the
of reopening prematurely is great but I
think the frustration if I think of
children in particular the the risk
benefit ratio of a child being at home
potentially away from enhanced nutrition
without the parent able to work because
to school provides daycare without the
monitoring as sometimes occurs for
incidences such as child abuse but
perhaps most importantly for all
children the opportunity cost of a brain
which is forming not having access to
the information that will help that
brain form optimally now as there have
been any sort of kind of risk benefit
ratio for the child yes they are risk
for callous Aki's but they are a
particular risk for missing out on a
year of education particularly for those
from less and rich backgrounds
I guess I'm very concerned about that
tension what are your thoughts on that
know you very difficult of the
unintended consequences of trying to do
something that broadly is important for
the public health and the risk of having
a return or resurgence of an outbreak
and the unintended deleterious
consequences of having children out of
school we fully appreciate that I don't
have an easy answer to that
I just don't just have to sleep on a
step-by-step basis as we get into the
period of time with the fall about
reopening the schools exactly where
we'll be in the dynamics of the outbreak
I might point out something that I think
has been alluded to throughout some of
the questions and we have a very large
country and the dynamics of the outbreak
on different in different regions of the
country so I would imagine that
situations regarding school will be very
different in one region versus another
so that it's not going to be universally
or homogeneous but I don't have a good
explanation a solution and the problem
of what happens when you close schools
and it triggers a cascade of events that
could have some common circumstances I
I've mr. chairman I'll close by asking
permission of the
of the chair to submit for the record an
article that just came out in the
Journal of pediatric nursing children
are at risk week Ovid 19b so it'll be
included Thank You senator senator
Warren Thank You mr. Thank You mr.
chairman and thank you to our witnesses
for being here today I hope everybody
staying safe and healthy in the past 16
weeks over 1.3 million Americans have
been infected with corona fires we now
know that about 80,000 people have died
and 33 million people are out of work
dr. Falchi you have advised six
residents you have battled deadly
viruses fear in their career so I just
like to hear your honest opinion we have
the corona virus contained huh
senator thank you for the question right
now it depends on what you mean by
containment if you think that we have it
completely under control I mean if you
look at the dynamics of the outbreak we
are seeing a diminution of
hospitalizations and infections in some
places such as in New York City which
has plateaued and starting to come down
New Orleans but in other parts of the
country we are seeing spikes so when you
look at dynamics of new cases even
though some are coming down they there
the curve looks flat with some slight
coming down so I think we're going in
the right direction but the right
direction does not mean we have by any
means total control of this outbreak so
right direction as I understand it we
have about 25,000 new infections a day
and over 2,000 deaths a day I think
those are the right numbers and some are
estimating we could be at 200,000 cases
a day by genes is that right dr. Khatri
I don't I don't foresee that as 200,000
new cases by June
I am hoping and looking at the dynamics
of things starting to flatten off and
come down that we will be much much
better than that senator
just just so I understand we are right
now at 2,000 new infections a day and
two 25,000 new infections he take and
2,000 guests a day right and that's
where we are right now yeah yeah yeah so
let me just ask it we know that it is
possible to get this virus under better
control other countries have done it
like South Korea but we are now three
months into this pandemic and basically
we've continued to set records for the
number of people who are diagnosed and
the number of people who died dr. Falchi
you recently said that a second wave of
rotavirus in the fall was quote
inevitable but that if America puts in
place all of the countermeasures that
you need to address this we should do
reasonably well and the countermeasures
you identified are things like continued
social distancing significantly more
testing widespread contact tracing you
also said that if America doesn't do
what it takes and this is your quote we
could be in for a bad fall in a bad
winter so right now we're about 16 weeks
away from Labor Day that's about the
same length of time since the virus was
first detected here in the US don't you
have enough robust Helder measures in
place that we don't have to worry about
a bad fall in winter right now the
projection as you heard from Admiral Joe
law with regard the testing and other
elements that would be needed to respond
the projection is that by the time we
get to the end of the summer and early
fall and we will have that in place and
I think the projection I get from you we
don't have it in place now but we are
projecting the will happen in place and
let me just ask the other side of this
if we don't do better on testing on
contact tracing and on social distancing
we'll deaths from coronavirus
necessarily increase of course if you do
not do an
adequate response we will have the
deleterious consequence of more
infections and more deaths and that's
the reason right you quoted me senator
quite correctly everything you said and
I will stand by that if we do not
respond in an adequate way when the fall
comes even that it is without a doubt
that there will be infections that will
be in the community and we run the risk
of having a resurgence
I would hope by that point in time in
the fall now we have more than enough to
respond adequate but if we don't there
will be problems
I appreciate your hope and I wish we
could tell the American people that the
federal government has this pandemic
under control but we can't in fact we've
said that the virus is not under control
in the US we haven't yet taken the
measures necessary to prevent a second
wave of death and we all know that the
people who are going to be most affected
are going to be seniors essential
workers the people who are out on the
front lines the president needs to stop
pretending that if he just ignores bad
news it will go away
it won't the time for magical thinking
is over here
president Trump must acknowledge that
the federal response has been
insufficient and that more people are
dying as a result we are running out of
time
to save lives and we need to act now so
thank you dr. Tsao to you for all you're
doing appreciate it but the urgency of
the moment not thank you thank you
senator Warren senator Roberts thank you
much mr. chairman and thanks to all the
witnesses you all are like the the Fab
Four I guess it was a fair fire back in
the day but we're shining the light of
truth in the darkness that individual
flashlights for sure Thank You mr.
chairman for emphasizing that we have to
be bipartisan this approach we're not to
get anywhere and to that obviously is in
the eyes of the beholder I'm happy to
say that we have a very good
relationship Governor Kelly who happens
to be a Democrat obvious murder pup and
her Emir to her emergency management is
spot-on
utterly enormous doing enough a job
that's the rest of this morning I talked
to Lee Scituate and Kant is a very good
I'm reading here Candice receives
seventh up two new covetous for
Catholics with food processing
facilities you see this mural behind me
that's the stage boots coming into Dodge
as opposed to getting out of Dodge Dodge
City is my hometown at BR the hot spot
in regards to Candace mainly because of
two packing plants we have five that's
26 percent of the cattle market as any
great Candace is going through a tough
time it we shouldn't be worried about
the safety of the food supply chain
I think nationwide is under a great deal
of stress we see that in dairy we see
that in poultry we see that import there
euthanizing pigs in office attend
obviously the livestock industry sonny
Perdue with the Department of
Agriculture has stepped up so is the
president declaring that these packing
plants are a national asset we progress
city when we first started out had five
tests five that's between four and six
five it's not 50 million as we hope to
receive that has been said by one of the
witnesses the reason I am really harping
on all of the problems were having an
act poacher on top of the fact that the
relationship of China is
I said even first breakthrough with
regards to trade to China seems to be on
hold on
and that's another price depressant man
this is going on five or six years where
our prices have been below the post
production end result our consumers are
really figuring out that food doesn't
come from grocery store and I'm very
worried that the harm to food value
chain is is very real not to mention the
financial situation that our farmers
ranchers and the growers all faced now
having said all that I want to ask
Admiral Zhao are you spoken about the
importance of having diversity in kinds
of tests that are available the five
packing plants we have in campus if we
could get a rapid test and we could get
it as we hopefully asked for because of
the hot spots that are developing not
only in Kansas but also doing great harm
for the food value chain that would be
absolutely wonderful would you speak to
that sir yes Thank You senator both dr.
red Phil and I have been very actively
involved in getting strategies or the
industry particularly in Kansas we are
supplying very heavily the public health
labs with rapid Diagnostics as well as
surging them to to areas like that so
the one trade-off however is that the
rapid the quote rapid point of care
Diagnostics are very slow so each
machine can only do four per hour and
that's very very slow so it's a mix of
testing that you need at these kinds of
situations on sort of the high
throughput tests that are available at a
major lab a quest lab right there in
Kansas as well as a mix of the rapid
testing and that's what we're supplying
in order to provide a comprehensive
holistic solution and I believe CDC's on
the ground as well in Kansas supporting
that I appreciate that if you're only
doing for an hour that's not a rapid
test maybe it's a rapid slow test I'm
not quite sure how you define that
but I for one think that as we reopen
and by the way governor Kelley started
the opening process first of this month
on this May 18 and then we go to June
and then the hope is we hope not but we
do have contingency plans that if that
doesn't work as aptly described by dr.
Falchi type I think will be right but
this is going to be a tough go I have to
tell you that in terms of Agriculture
we're not in good shape I appreciate
everybody and the job that you were
doing we'll stand beside you when you're
taking the booze and behind you when
you're taking pass thank you senator
Roberts senator Kaine Thank You mr.
chair to the committee leadership and
witnesses for calling this important
hearing the last time doctor foul Qi and
Hahn were before us was March 3 I have a
slide that I want to put up that shows
what's happened in America since then
the chart which is here compares the
experience of the United States in South
Korea on three days On January 21 both
nations experienced their first case of
Kovan 19 at that time the unemployment
rates in both countries were essentially
identical on March 3 when the witnesses
were last here South Korea had
experienced 28 Cova 19 deaths in the
u.s. they experienced nine again the
economies of both nations is measured by
the unemployment rates were nearly
identical but now the story changes as
of yesterday more than 81 thousand
Americans have died and the US economy
has experienced job losses not seen
since the Great Depression
meanwhile the economy of South Korea has
not changed dramatically at all and the
death toll is now at 256 South Korea is
smaller than the United States one-sixth
of our population but even if you bulk
up the death toll to reflect the
difference the per capita death toll in
the u.s. is more than 45 times the rate
in South Korea and the healthcare
carnage here is causing a near
depression while South Korea has
protected its economy by managing
correctly I could have done this chart
with other nations the US has the
seventh highest per capita death rate in
the world our death
is off-the-charts higher than that in
India Australia New Zealand Japan and
Mexico
it's nearly three times the death rate
in Germany twice as high as Canada's
rate the question is why if we want to
open up our economy in schools we have
to learn the lessons of Nations that
have managed as well here are some
things that don't explain the difference
our hospitals are as good or better than
those in South Korea our health care
providers heroes are as good or better
than those in South Korea our research
capacity is as good or better than South
that in South Korea and we have more
resources than South Korea our GDP is 12
times
South Korea's and our per capita income
is 50% higher so to doctor foul Qi the
death roll in the United States the
death rate in the United States
especially when compared with other
nations is unacceptable isn't it sorry
sir
yes of course I mean a death rate that
high is something that in any matter of
form in my mind is unacceptable and
doctor foul Qi the experience of other
nations shows that the u.s. death rate
is not only unacceptable but it's
unnecessary
isn't that correct I don't I I don't
know if we can say that Saturday but
would you say that the US has to do
better of course you always have to do
better I mean as a and and the
experience of South Korea shows that how
a nation manages the healthcare crisis
has a huge impact also it's an on it's
economic condition isn't that the case
that is the case sir I understand where
you're going with this but I have to
tell you there is a big difference
between South Korea and the United
States you know the outbreak and let and
let me and let me get to that I want to
get to factors that do explain the
difference since we know it's not
resources or our health providers first
is testing South Korea began began
aggressive testing much earlier than the
US now in the fifth month of the
pandemic we've surpassed South Korea in
per capita testing but in the critical
month of March South Korea was testing
its population at a rate of 40
the testing in the u.s. admiral gerard
dr. gerard has set out the standard for
us when we get to september he says the
United States needs to do 40 to 50
million tests a month to be safe that
equates to about 1.3 million to 1.7
million tests a day yesterday we did 395
thousand tests we've got a long way to
go a second factor is contract race
contact tracing South Korea embraced a
rigorous contact tracing program right
from the beginning the United States
still has not engaged in a national
contract tack tracing program isn't that
right with that by dr. pouches dr.
Redfield
so I think that question would best be
directed to the CDC when the outbreak
started - sir we had an aggressive
contact tracing program but
unfortunately as the cases rose it went
beyond the capacity of me we went to
mitigation so we lost the the
containment as clearly and that was key
to the economy as well because South
Korea did testing contact tracing
protect serve isolate the sick and then
they didn't have to do the shutdowns
which helped their economy social
distancing is a third factor we've
talked about it but finally the last one
healthcare systems would you agree with
me that it helps keep people safer
either from serious conditions or death
from kovin 19 if they have access to
healthcare yes of course of course of
course that's the case in South Korea
ninety seven percent of the population
have health insurance in the United
States before Kovan nineteen millions
didn't have it and lacked access to
health care the massive job losses in
the last month's threatened to take
health insurance away from millions more
and President Trump is doing all he can
to dismantle the Affordable Care Act
which would take health insurance away
from tens of millions more let's learn
the lessons from those who are doing
this right Thank You mr. chair I yield
back
make a clarification please mr. chairman
this is up breath sure why I just wanted
to clarify that
I did project that we will have the
ability to perform 40 to 50 million
tests per month in in that timeframe but
I said if needed that that at that time
I am NOT making a proclamation we have
to really understand what where the
epidemic is what the community spread is
before we can ask to mate the number of
tests that are needed i was simply
stating the fact that our combination of
testing capabilities will be at that
level even barring on new input from the
nih thank you very much senator cane
senator muskie Thank You mr. chairman
and gentlemen thank you for being here
this morning ritually but also for all
you have been doing for these many many
months
Alaska's doing okay right now from a
numbers perspective and quite honestly
we want to keep it that way because we
know we have exceptionally vulnerable
populations we know we have a geography
that is challenging we know that we have
facilities that are very limited last
hearing we had an opportunity to hear
from dr. Collins and he shared where
they are with the red X and also spoke
to red X up which was very interesting
about what we can be doing in rural
areas but but focusing on hotspots and
as I reminded him we don't want to be a
hot spot in Alaska so every effort that
we make to keep the virus out of of
Alaska is our lives that are saved I him
on the community of Cordova that is just
getting ready to open its its Copper
River salmon fishery
in two days and was able to share that
they had had one worker tested positive
as he was coming in from the lower 48 to
come to work the good news on that is
that all the protocols that we have put
in place seemed to be working the
quarantine the isolation not only for
that individual but for others that he
had come in contact were secured so I
want I want to recognize the assistance
that we have received from the
administration dr. Eastman is in the
state
at this moment the the chief medical
officer for the Department of Homeland
Security going out to rural communities
to really better understand our our
vulnerabilities go to some of our
fishing communities to again understand
how we can successfully prosecute a
fisheries when you have to bring workers
in from the outside we thank you for the
assistance with regards to additional
testing capacity I've been in in contact
with our chief medical officer the state
this morning and the mayor of Cordova
just better understanding again do we
have the tests that we need what do we
need on the ground and one of the things
that that I would like to have clarified
and this is probably to you dr. Shu
khabees because you have been so helpful
and kind of shining the light on what we
need to be doing in these rural areas
but so much of the focus has been on hot
spots and responding to the hot spots
but how do you keep those rural remote
small communities from becoming the hot
spots in the first place are we doing
enough and right now the strategy has
been we just lock it off the travel
restrictions that are in place are
apparently working but they're also
they're also devastating our economy
whether it's tourism whether it's our
resource industries or whether it's the
potential for our fisheries so Admiral
if you might speak to to that aspect of
it and then I have a very important
question as it relates to contract
contact tracing that I'd like to direct
to either Admiral yaw or dr. Redfield
Thank You senator and as you know you
have an outstanding state health officer
and doctor and zinc and we do I've had
the privilege of working with her and
you have a very good protocol in trying
to keep Alaska safe by isolation over a
period of time when you come in as you
know we also work with the state to
your your very challenging testing
requirements because you can't really
you know then laughs out a thousand
miles away so we put a real customized
mixed at point of care and also the
Cepheid machines I think we sent nine or
ten new to Alaska and about fifty
thousand test which is about four times
then you've done to date collectively in
order to provide that support so again I
do think there's a comprehensive
strategy that you do have but again the
mitigation is to the degree that you can
given the circumstances the face mask
the hand-washing the hygiene we
understand fully the challenges
particularly in the fishing river
environment and the remote but all these
have to come together the testing the
tracing the mitigation the hygiene
factors to try to keep your community
safe and we really understand culturally
that many of your communities were
almost annihilated in the 1918 influenza
pandemic so in that memory is still very
sharp and very hurtful to many of the
citizens though we want to do our best
to assure them that we're giving them
all the protection we can Merle let me
let me turn to dr. Redfield because this
relates to contact tracing I think this
is a very very key part of how we move
forward into getting people back to work
getting people back to school right now
we have about a hundred people that are
involved and in contact tracing in
Alaska that's clearly not sufficient
there's been talk about a national
strategy but I think we recognize that
we have teams in place whether it's
America or whether it's Peace Corps
whether it's are our public health corps
what more do we need to be doing to make
sure that once you've been tested
positive you know then what happens
after that who else needs to be brought
into into this and I'm not convinced
that we're focusing enough on that
aspect of how we move to to reopening if
we haven't done the contact tracing
thank you very much senator I want to
just reinforce what you said I think
contact tracing capabilities
is critical it's going to be the
difference from succeeding in in
containing this outbreak from once again
using wide scale community transmission
or not we're positioned as you know to
deploy redeployed the number of CDC over
500 CDC individuals we have another
about 650 that you're trying to put into
our foundation but most importantly
we're trying to work with your health
department with the resources that we've
been able to give because of the
Congress the mentals also as you
mentioned with these other agencies with
LabCorp I mean with America or with the
Census Bureau to work together and have
the state develop their cutting capacity
some states have reacted state work some
states of react in a National Guard
while they begin to do this but I agree
with you and I said it's gonna be and
they see a significant effort to build
the contact capacity that we need in
this nape state-by-state but it's gonna
need to be augmented probably in your
state from what you just said hold and
we're there to work with the states to
help them accomplish that needs to get
in place before September here we need
to move on it thank you
Thank You senator Murkowski I don't want
to get any senator off but we have eight
more senators we have five minute rounds
and and it's 12:30 so I'd request that
the Senators and the witnesses succinct
questions and try to stay within five
minutes would be appreciated senator
hassle
well thank you mr. chair thank you and
the ranking member for having this
hearing and thank you to our witnesses
today and please pass our thanks along
to all of the hard-working women and men
in your agencies who I know have been
working virtually around the clock to
try to improve our response and keep
Americans safe and mr. chair I hope you
and all the witnesses are healthy and
safe today as is everybody on your team
I wanted to start by echoing comments my
colleagues have made about eating
leadership from the CDC and our public
health experts on how we are going to
use facts and evidence as guidance so
that our schools and our daycares and
our businesses have the information they
need to create safe and sustainable
plans to reopen and of course that means
too that our testing capacity not only
has to be enough but it has to be
flexible enough to meet our needs the
key distinction between South Korea and
the United States is not how many tests
per capita over a certain amount of time
we've done but the fact that at the
onset of this pandemic South Korea was
much more able to do a lot more tests
per capita than we were and then follow
that with all the other measures you've
talked about so that we continue to need
to identify the need and then build our
capacity towards the need not the other
way around I wanted to start with a
question to you dr. pouchy first of all
thank you for your work and your
expertise I wanted to talk about nursing
homes for a minute New Hampshire and
across the country a huge number of the
deaths from Kovac 19 that we are seeing
have been in nursing homes we all know
people who have lost a friend or a
family member in nursing homes and the
brief compounded by the fact that people
couldn't be at the loved ones Benson
right if they died yesterday dr. Burks
said that all 1 million nursing home
residents should be tested within the
next two weeks as well as all nursing
home staff dr. pouchy as a short-term
goal that makes sense to me but after
that what will the ongoing federal
recommendations look like how frequently
do we need to test patients and staff on
a continuing basis and what other
measures will be necessary to keep our
loved ones in these facilities safe
thank you for the question of single
hassen the the general plan as you
mentioned that was recommended by dr.
Burks is a sound plan as you said in the
immediate question is in the long range
we will have to
of infection control capabilities in
nursing homes that are really pristine
and it really unassailable we have to do
the kinds of surveillances and have to
have the capability of when you identify
someone you get out of that particular
environment so that they don't spread
the infection throughout some general
testing for all I think is a good start
but when you look what are you gonna go
in the future it has to be a
considerable degree of surveillance
capability thank you doctor the White
House is now requiring all staff to wear
masks and anyone in regular contact with
the president tested daily do you think
nursing homes should implement those
same measures to help make sure that our
seniors can get the same level of
protection I think there should be a
system in place the optimal protection
of people in nursing homes and that
would be necessarily testing every
person every day that's one approach
that might not be practical when you
think of all the nursing homes in the
country but strict regulations and
guidelines about who is allowed to go
into the nursing home and the staff I
believe needs to be monitored very
carefully with intermittent testing to
make sure that we don't have
introduction into the nursing home of
infected individuals I'm not sure you
can practically do it testing every day
that I don't think would be feasible but
something that is much more aggressive
than has been in the past I believe
should be done well thank you I have one
last question for dr. flood she and dr.
Redfield I would also just say that if
we are able to get masks to everybody in
the White House I hope we can get masks
to every nursing home employee needs it
dr. Fauci and dr. Redfield
US needs to be preparing now to ensure
that we have a stand in facture and
administer vaccines something you've
both touched on both for an eventual
hope in 19 vaccine as well as other
illnesses such as the flu the failure to
ramp up production of testing and
personal protective equipment early on
during this crisis
made things worse here that those
mistakes can't be repeated when it comes
to vaccine production and distribution
we are already seeing reports that some
children are not receiving routine
immunizations as it becomes more
difficult to access in-person care
doctor pouchy what steps should we take
now to ensure that we have sufficient
manufacturing and distribution capacity
or a Copa 19 vaccine without putting at
risk our capacity manufacture and
distribute other important products such
as a flu or measles vaccine and my
follow-up question to dr. Redfield would
be what efforts are underway at CDC to
ensure that all routine vaccines are
accessible during the kovat 19 public
health emergency yeah thank you for that
question senator Hasson I'll answer it
as quickly as possible I alluded to this
in my introductory remarks when I was
talking about vaccines for coping 19 and
what we said as we do the testing on
these vaccines we are gonna make
production at risk which means we will
start putting hundreds of millions of
dollars of federal government money into
the development and production of
vaccine doses before we even know it
works see that when we do and I hope we
will and I have cautious optimism that
we will ultimately get an effective and
safe vaccine now we will have doses
available to everyone who needs it in
the United States and even contribute to
the what is the needs globally because
we are partnering with a number of other
countries the other part of your
question about making sure that when we
get into a situation like the so called
shutdown that we might be in now and we
make sure that children get the
vaccinations that they need because that
would be an unintended consequence of
shutting down as we are right now it's a
very good point we want to make sure we
don't fall behind on that also thank you
thank you very much and I'll take my
answer from dr. Redfield offline thank
you so much for allowing me to go Thank
You senator Hasson senator Scott Thank
You mr. chairman into the panel thank
you all for being here virtually without
any question we find ourselves in a
situation that we wish we were not I'm
very thankful for folks like dr. Burks
dr. Fauci and many others for your
dedication 24
seven without any question our nation is
safer because of your hard work I want
to direct my question estores dr. Falchi
really one specific question dr. Falchi
and I'm thinking about the reopening of
America and specifically the reopening
of South Carolina and I'm taking into
consideration the fact that in South
Carolina I think overall our cases are
moving in the right direction we have a
little less than 8,000 cases
unfortunately 350 deaths our hospital
capacity is actually better now than it
was when the pandemic started our
ability to isolate hot spots and
mitigate the spread of the virus is I
think where it needs to be with that in
mind I flew into Washington from South
Carolina yesterday we have plans to test
additionally 220,000 more residents by
the end of this month focusing on
at-risk populations by the end of this
month we will have tested 100% 100% of
nursing home residents and the staff
that takes care of them and after
increasing our contact tracing workforce
twenty fold in the matter of weeks our
state's Health Department announced
yesterday that we're going to increase
it by an additional 1,400 contact
tracers we have built and we continue to
build the tools necessary to better
detect and isolate cases to map their
exposure and to prevent substantial
spikes moving forward most importantly
our health care system thanks to in part
to flexibilities from this
administration has the beds and the
equipment necessary to address the most
serious cases when they arise
now with these tools in hand we have
begun to reopen to be clear we continue
to scale up testing and to make to take
measure to protect the most vulnerable
and the data points are increasingly
clear for older Americans and for those
with chronic conditions like diabetes
and high blood pressure
this virus remains a threat a dangerous
threat a recent report suggests that in
New York roughly 90% of the fatalities
had underlying issues two-thirds of
fatalities were 70 years
or older 95% over the age of 50 in South
Carolina the meeting age of patients who
have died from the virus seventy six and
a half nearly two-thirds of fatalities
have been patients older than 71 and
nearly 90% were over the age of 60 and
roughly 98 percent in South Carolina are
over the age of 50
contrast that with those aged 20 and
younger where we've seen no deaths fewer
than 1% of deaths in my state have been
under the age of 40 every single death
is a tragedy every single one and we
mourn what our family members have lost
their loved ones we are taking every
measure to protect our older South
Carolinians as well as those with
underlying conditions but when we set
out to flatten the curve by taking
aggressive unprecedented measures like
staying at home orders and mass small
business closures we didn't set out with
the goal of preventing 100% fatalities
that would be unrealistic
it is impossible and we didn't set out
to keep quarantines in place until we
found a safe and effective vaccine that
would take too long dr. Redfield your
agency put out a helpful graphic showing
two curves long to respite quickly and
Pete high reflected daily cases without
protective measures the other flatter
curve showed cases with those measures
in place and the whole point which the
graphic Illustrated was to make sure
that we did not exceed hospital capacity
so while I respect the need for caution
we are too often presented with a false
dichotomy either saving our economy are
saving lives we've seen the goalposts
around flattening the curve move and I
think that's unfortunate because at the
same time we're doing that businesses of
the collapsed mental and physical health
have declined depths of despair escalate
educate
outcomes nosedive as we wait in our
living room spraying for some good news
around therapies and around vaccines we
set out to flatten the curve and I think
we've done a pretty good job with that
we need to do better and we will do
better my question dr. Fauci is as we
start the process of moving towards
reopening South Carolina what else would
you suggest that we could do to protect
our most vulnerable populations Thank
You senator Scott you gave a really very
eloquent description of what I think is
one a would be a model way the way
you've approached this I mean you have
put things in place that I think would
optimize your capability of reopening
and I was as I was thinking as you were
speaking I almost want to clone that and
make sure other people hear about that
and see what you've been doing the issue
of your direct question to me about the
vulnerable populations is that as we
have said in our guidelines and I looks
like you are ready to progress carefully
because you put into place a very good
system that the vulnerable the elderly
and those with underlying conditions
should be those who at the very last
lifting of mitigations should be those
who are left in a situation where they
might be in danger of getting infected
in other words protect them right up
until the very end of the relaxation of
your mitigation because as you said very
correctly those are the individuals now
the most vulnerable so the morbidity and
the mortality so those of individuals
particularly I might say sir those in
Demon's already grew the
african-american and Hispanics who for a
variety of situations that are the
social determinants of health have a
greater likelihood of not only getting
infected but of also having the
underlying conditions that would make
their risk for a high degree in
morbidity mortality higher so it looks
like you're doing things very very well
and I would encourage you to
you and to follow the guidelines as you
get closer to normalizing your state
thank you thank you dr. Fallon I'll just
simply close with this it's amount of
time thank you for the many
conversations that you and I have had
about those vulnerable populations to
include minorities as well as our senior
citizens I will say that without any
question when you look at nursing homes
as typically african-americans and
Hispanics are the certified nursing
assistants who are providing care for
the elderly population so your focus on
those two very vulnerable groups is much
appreciated and thank you for your
expertise Thank You senator Scott and
Senator Smith thank you so much sherry
Alexander for being here today and for
your service and dr. Fauci I have to say
you're in the unenviable position trust
to give us the straight scoop and tell
us what's really happening you're about
the facts and not about the politics and
that's a really good thing simply I have
to start by asking a question that I
think a lot of a lot of Americans want
to know which is how are you doing I'm
doing fine senator thank you very much
for asking this is this is such an
important problem it transcends all of
us individually it has to be working as
a team and and I enjoy very much working
with your senators and the governors
because it's at the local level that
we're gonna make this thing works I'm
fine I appreciate your concern well a
lot of people are thinking about you and
are grateful for your service as we are
for all of you you know so we're
gathered today to think about what we
need to do to reopen our economy and I
think first about what's happening in my
home state of Minnesota where
agriculture is such an important part of
how our state works it's a part of our
history in our pork processors right now
are looking at the reality of
euthanizing thousands of hogs a day
because there is no place to process
them because of what's happening in the
processing plants and the working people
who do the hard work in those processing
plants
are getting sick so here's one story
this is a one worker the Star Tribune
wrote about this named hamari DeJesus
she's an asylum seeker and a mom who
works for a contractor that does the
cleaning in the processing plants and
she works for $14 an hour 7 hours a day
five days a week and her job is to
sanitize the machines that process the
the meat into a ground meat and she
started feeling sick on April 11th but
she kept going to work and on April 21st
when one of her co-workers fainted she
told her supervisor that she felt sick
and so she was told to go home but that
if she didn't show any signs of illness
she should come back she went to the
doctor and she paid a hundred and
fifteen dollars to get a test and found
out a few days later that she was kovat
positive and she's still at home she's
still she's not getting paid and she
doesn't have health insurance and nearly
two weeks ago President Trump
deployed the defense production act to
keep these processing plants open but
the USDA gave really limited guidance
about what would be safe for those
workers it said for example in response
to testing which has been such a big
part of what we've been talking about
today they said this is a quote
facilities should consider the
appropriate role of testing in workplace
contact tracing of Kovach 19 positive
workers in a worksite and assessment so
doctor fat she is we think about how we
move forward we all want to open up the
economy what what guidance would you
give us in a situation like this here in
Minnesota well I can give you my
common-sense guidance although this is
not the area of my expertise it's more
in others but it would seem that if you
want to keep things like acting plants
open that you've really got to provide
the optimum degree of protection of the
work is involved the ability to allow
them to go to work safely and if and
when
individuals get infected to immediately
be able to get them out and given the
proper care so I would think when you're
calling upon people to perform essential
services you really have no Mis tomorrow
responsibility to make sure they are
well taken care of and well protected
and again that's not an official
proclamation that's just me speaking as
a physician and as a human being thank
you doctor kouchi and I think that you
speak as a human being but you also
speak as the chief epidemiologist of our
country and the person that we are the
tools that we if we are we all want to
do and this we move forward with
reopening our economy and yet we still
have circumstances like we have in these
processing plants and in other places
around the state we are going to be
we're gonna be right back where we
started and except even in the worst
place as I think you pointed out dr.
Thank You senator and and again it
really does relate to one of the
questions that one of your colleagues
senators asked me before that one of the
things that I keep emphasizing and I'll
just repeat it again because it's
support that when you are in the process
of opening up and pulling back on
mitigation you really must have in place
the capability of responding when you do
have the inevitable upticks in cases
that will absolutely occur it's how we
deal with it and how successful we are
in putting the clamps on it that will
prevent us from getting the kind of
rebound and not only from the standpoint
of illness and death would be something
that's unacceptable but it will set us
back in our progress so it's reopening
the country thank you very much senator
Smith senator Rama this hearing at the
participants in it
Admiral Jawara I'm going to take off
where senator Haas and
I understand that politicians are gonna
frame data in a way that's most positive
politically of course they don't expect
that from Admirals but yesterday you
celebrated that we had done more tests
and more tests per capita even than
South Korea but you ignored the fact
that they accomplished theirs at the
beginning of the outbreak
well we treaded water during February
and March and and as a result by March
6th
the US had completed just 2,000 tests
whereas South Korea had conducted more
than a hundred and forty thousand tests
so partially as a result of that they
have 256 deaths and we have almost
80,000 deaths
I find our testing record nothing to
celebrate whatsoever
the fact is their test numbers are going
down down down down now because they
don't have the kind of outbreak we have
they have to I think that's an important
lesson for us as we think about the
future on a separate topic my impression
is that with regards to vaccines that
we're I'm critical of what we've done on
testing and vaccines we've done a pretty
darn good job moving ahead pretty
aggressively and yet the president said
the other day that President Obama is
responsible for our lack of a vaccine he
add dr. Fauci is President Obama or by
extension President Trump did they do
something that made the likelihood of
creating a vaccine less likely are
either President Trump or President
Obama responsible for the fact that we
don't have a vaccine now or in delaying
it in some in some way no no senator not
not at all certainly President Obama nor
President Trump are responsible for not
having a vaccine we moved as you said
because I described it in my opening
statement rather rapidly no one is ever
gone from knowing what the virus was to
a phase one trial as fast as we've done
so I don't think that's something that
once you'd say anybody's responsible for
doing anything wrong on that I think
that's right that's the correct way to
do it
thank you that that was my impression I
was surprised by the comment but that
was my impression dr. Redfield senator
cinema and I wrote a letter to you
expressing our dismay at the lack of
real
I'm data at the CDC I'm talking about
granular demographic hospitalization
treatment data how is it possible in
this day and age that the CDC has never
established such a real-time system with
accurate data and and what can Congress
do to rectify that so we never have to
look at something like this again
oh there you go sorry senator thanks for
the question I think you hit one of the
important they are the first one I focus
on is data data modernization data
analytics and predictive data analysis
clearly Congress has forward in
providing funding for a data
modernization and we're in the process
of implemented there the reality is
there there's an archaic system a non
integrated public health system each
Public Health Department has their own
systems this nation needs a modern
highly capable a data analytic system
that can do predictive analysis I think
it's one of the many shortcomings that
have been identified as we went through
this outbreak and I couldn't agree with
you more
it's time to get that corrected thank
you please help guide us as to what we
need to do to make sure that happens
that I presume it's not filled at
ourselves but work with companies that
have that capacity and use that capacity
in our favorite doctor if out you want
one last thing which relates to a virus
that I I know I'm asking you the
impossible question but we're all hoping
for a vaccine obviously it's the
objective of our administration to get
it as soon as they can and from what I
can tell they're pulling out all the
stops to do exactly that given our
history with vaccine creation for other
coronaviruses how likely is it I mean is
it extremely likely we're going to get a
vaccine within a year or two is it just
more likely than not or is it kind of a
long shot it's definitely not a long
shot Senator Romney I would think that
it is more likely than not that we will
because this is a virus that induces an
immune response that people recover the
overwhelming majority of people recover
from this virus although there is good
morbidity and mortality at a level in
certain populations the very fact that
the body is capable of spontaneously
clearing the virus tells me and at least
from
sexual standpoint we can stimulate the
body with a vaccine that would induce a
similar response so although there's no
guarantee I think it clearly much more
likely than not that somewhere within
that timeframe we will get a vaccine for
this virus Thank You mr. chairman I
yield Thank You senator Romney I want to
thank the witnesses for their patience
we have four more senators and we'd like
to give them a chance to ask their
questions so senator Jones thank you
very very much mr. chairman and thanks
to all our witnesses for your being here
virtually and also for your incredible
service during this time I want to
follow up real quick with a an
additional statistic that Senator Romney
talked about with regard to South Korea
and that is the fact that you're a
nation that has about six times the
population of South Korea but yet we
have about 310 times the number of
deaths from this pandemic so I think we
have to be very careful in making
comparisons around the world
comparing the United States to other
countries dr. Redfield I want to follow
up just a little bit with what Senator
Murkowski and I think senator Kaine
talked a little bit about contact
tracing and where we're going I
understand you are working with States
to try to develop plans for reopening
the testing is important the contact
tracing is important but using that data
as well is also going to be important in
terms of the quarantine plans that
Senator Murphy talked about child care
facilities to have allow people to put
their kids in a facility while they are
still go back to work all of those
issues including maybe even facilities
like vacant hotels or motels that may be
used for self isolation how is this plan
being developed within the CDC is are
those plans going to be individualized
by state will we as a member of Congress
be access to those plans and how how are
states going to pay for these and I
think that because my state's already
using the money that we've already given
them as a wishlist I mean they're
talking about building 200
million-dollar State House
as opposed to developing the test and
doing the contact tracing so I'd like to
through just to drill down a little bit
on how these plants are going to develop
what access we will have to have those
plans and be able to see them thank you
very much senator this is obviously said
before there's a critical component of
us take this time to become how to get
prepared for a next fall the winter and
building that comprehensive contact
racing capacity we're working
individually with the leadership of the
state health department's the local
departments territorial tribal to try to
let them get us to understand what they
think their capacity needs are and those
discussions have already happens as
happened with her are said there's been
a variety of federal H together on
testing and contact tracing CDC's in
position that we've reprogrammed our
individuals that we have across the
country were 500 begin to help each of
these states we amended that with some
additional personnel that we're bringing
on board state by state foundation we've
about a hundred and six billion dollars
of the money that Congress has
appropriated into the states so they can
begin to start thinking about how do
they want to hire return contact tracing
capability and then of course it was
mentioned that we're all other
government programs like AmeriCorps
this is Peace Corps now that each group
is going to extract their contact
tracing piece what they think their
needs are and I do think it is gonna be
similar to what we heard from the
senator from South Carolina these are
significant increases he said he
incredibly falled anything that they're
gonna increase again but the point you
brought up is so critically important
and we found that as we already
struggled through the repatriation of
different Americans from around the
country where we had to put many of
these in quarantine as you know using
military bases because many of the state
local health department's really
developed that system where do they put
somebody who to be in isolation who's
homeless
how do you develop the system so this
has to be part of it too
is it there's there certain a city
that's intrinsic for its it hotels as
you mentioned the point that was made by
one of the other senators is so
important about individuals that
particular like they the Meatpacking the
individual that has to go home and self
isolate but maybe have ability to go
home and so if I sleek in a multi
general general generation analyst with
about 12 other people mechanisms to be
brought in they have an effective way to
identify cases don't like the X and then
do the appropriate public health measure
and that these have to be comprehensive
it's gonna be developed on jurisdiction
than a cat atop AIESEC no reason why
these are not transparent documents as
they get it completed and it really is a
tribute to what the congressional
support that you've given so far as I
said one point six billion dollars got
into the state and then again to do this
in addition of the resources that we've
gotten but it is fundamental people
underestimate how important it is we
have a highly functional comprehensive
aggressive attack you seen program so
that the next to this outbreak we
contain them we don't have to switch our
mitigation alright thank you thank you
dr. Redfield I appreciate it it sounds
to me like we still got a lot of work to
do so thank you thank you very much
senator Jones senator broad Thank You
chairman been so much discussion about
testing in general listen to Senator
Romney earlier I think Senator Kaine
mentioned it
everybody has dr. Han if you remember
when we first met I said is the FDA
going to be more entrepreneurial is the
FDA going to kind of not be a stodgy
talking then about how we fix the health
care system in general now this has
brought it into clear focus I've got a
timeline and I'm gonna submit for the
record it shows from January 24th
through
March 5th and I want to emphasize what
senator burr ask earlier
has the administration ever put an
impediment in front of trying to get to
testing and dr. Hahn this will end up in
a question in a moment but there was a
span of time from January 24th through
March 5th that I hope the American
public looks at and it gets back to
what's wrong with our health care system
in general early testing from what I'm
seeing was created by the fact that the
CDC said it was going to do its own
tests the South Korean test that gets
cited so often was not going to be
looked at we had to do our own I know
the FDA worked with the CDC but the long
and short of all of this is that for
nearly a month this was in that
bureaucratic swirl the FDA prevented
private and academic development of
tests for weeks
the CDC decide denied access to
functioning tests as I cited in South
Korea this created through all the red
tape and bureaucracy to where we had to
come up with a one-size-fits-all
approach due to the uncertainty of the
virus and we are stuck with that now I
don't want to dwell on that necessarily
because I think those are mistakes that
we made I'm tired of having it heard
that it's the administration's fault dr.
Hahn I'd like to ask you this question
in that spirit of what we talked about
during your nomination process here
going forward will we shed some of that
stodgy nough swell we look to get
therapeutics and vaccines through the
system in a quicker method because I
fear if we don't and if we treat through
bureaucracy how we did the early period
of testing we can be labor this into the
distant future and at that point there's
going to be not only
the carnage from the disease itself but
from the economy to deal with so I'd
like your comment on that one month
stretch what accountability the FDA and
the CDC have and then whether it looks
better in terms of moving more quickly
into the future us Thank You senator
Braun for the question our timeline of
that period demonstrates that we began
working with test developers beyond CDC
on January 24th and had double digit
number of test developers working with
us one of the issues that we identified
was in fact availability of the virus
and other supplies to actually get that
test development done in a timely
fashion senator I completely agree with
you that this is an opportunity for us
to take a look and determine how we can
do things better and I think that's a
really important thing for all of us to
do and certainly the FDA I can promise
you will do that
looking forward sir I can commit to you
that we will look at every one of our
regulatory authorities we have done so
during this outbreak we have provided
significant flexibility and have tried
to provide the right balance between
regulatory flexibility and enabling of
the great test developers and
therapeutic developers in this country
with the need to ensure that our gold
standard of safety and advocacy is in
place we have leaned in with
manufacturers we've learned a lot from
them as well as the other stakeholders
and we will continue to learn and we
will I commit you sir implement the
changes that are necessary to make sure
that we can act in a more simple way but
still protect the safety and efficacy of
medical products thank you doctor foul
Qi taking a page from your anti-aids
playbook that implemented a formal
clearly defined treatment review pathway
can we do that
for kovat 19 in a similar parallel track
that you put into place
back then in the 90s in fact I've got a
bill called the promising pathways Act
that is based upon that protocol you put
into place can we do that
to more quickly get through to
therapeutics and vaccines here with
kovin 19 well it's it's a different
story but some similarities if you're
referring to the parallel track that I
put into place back in the in the late
80s which was when there was no
availability of drugs at all for HIV and
when we were testing drugs within a
protocol that we would make it available
outside of the protocol in what has
ultimately turned out to be
compassionate use so what we did is we
didn't want to interfere with the
integrity of the protocol to determine
in a control way what was safe and what
was effective but there was a dire need
for some sort of accessibility to those
drugs outside of a clinical trial for
those who might even have some chance of
having it and in fact that was really in
many respects the birth of a really firm
concept of compassionate use and in fact
there is a version of that which I'll
hand over to Commissioner on that is you
know when you have expanded access and
emergency use authorization the drugs
that have not yet been fully proven in a
clinical trial so there is somewhat of
an analogy and similarity between what I
did in the 1980s and what is actually
being done of the FDA now so Steve if
you might want to comment on that I
think that's right
dr. Falchi the emergency use
authorization process by statute allows
us to have flexibility and assess the
risk benefit ratio and a public health
emergency and we've done that on the
therapeutic side in three separate
occasions and continue to look at those
requests as they come in thank you very
much as you ever Thank You senator Braun
senator Rosen here I am Thank You mr.
chairman for bringing this hearing and I
want to thank the dedicated doctors
today for their a lifetime of work and
study and
question we are a grateful nation for
all of your your lifelong commitment in
fighting disease not just the United
States but around the world and you know
as I talked to Nevadans about safely
reopening the economy one question that
frequently comes up is when are we going
to have a vaccine like everyone's talked
about and Nevada travel and tourism of
course the lifeblood for us and the jobs
associated with those industries can
only fully come back if we know it's
safe to travel and visit our work at our
hotels casinos restaurants and
attractions ultimately to make this
happen we have to build confidence in
our visitors and it's safe we need a
vaccine and that research is extremely
important however understanding that
this takes time to develop and sure and
ensure both safety and efficacy I'd like
to hear more about what research is
happening regarding preventative
medication research it could be helpful
in the timeframe before a vaccine and
especially before one is widely
available so I'd like to ask if this
could be part of the path helping us
begin to reopen our economy safely and
bring visitors not only back to Nevada
but across our country so if dr. pouchy
what research is currently happening to
identify potential monoclonal antibody
preventative treatments or other
therapeutics if the right antibody is
identified or can be identified
would this be used as a preventive
medication to block Cova 19 virus from
latching onto those host cells
much like the treatments for rheumatoid
arthritis severe asthma or other
diseases and secondly would preventive
medication options like this
complement the effectiveness of X of a
vaccine once it's available yes so thank
you for that question senator Rosen
that's an excellent question and in all
of the therapeutic interventions that we
are developing and you mentioned several
of them they could be direct antivirals
along the line of REM the severe but
that's just an one of a number of
possibilities since there are several
viral targets Senate ratification cycle
using
lesson plasma and a preventive modality
as well as monoclonal antibodies and a
preventive modality are in fact all
feasible and will be pursued in parallel
with the development of a vaccine the
model of using drugs and other
interventions that are effective is
really a great success story in the
issue in hiv/aids because many of the
interventions that were developed for
the full treatment of an infected person
are exquisitely effective in preventing
infection of HIV so that's the kind of
model that we work out in parallel with
treatment for disease it's a using as
treatment as prevention I believe that
will be a part of our effort at the same
time as we're putting a full-court press
on trying to get a vaccine so it's an
excellent question very relevant I know
I have a hard time left so I'm just
gonna kind of abbreviate this the second
most important question that I get not
just from our first responders are
people worried about hurt but generally
what does the next generation of PPE
need to look like for all of us as we go
about our lives not just as workers it
depending on your work you may need
something stronger or more specific as
all of us as we want to go out with shop
or out to eat or whatever those things
are get on an airplane should mass be
made of a certain material blobs our
handkerchiefs defective can you talk
about PPE for the general public well
you know the best PPE for the general
public if possible right now is to
maintain the physical and social
distancing but as we've said and I think
all of us would agree there are certain
circumstances in which it is beyond your
control when you need to do necessary
things like go to the drugstore and get
the medication go to the grocery store
and get your food that in fact you need
some supplementation to just physical
distancing that's the reason why some
time ago the recommendation was made I
believe it was dr. Redfield at the CDC
who first said that about getting some
sort of a
covering we we don't want to call it a
mass because back then we were a concern
we'd be taking masks away from the
health care providers but some sort of
masks like facial covering I think for
the time being should be a very regular
part of how we prevent the spread of
infection and in fact the more and more
as you go outside right here and where
I'm sitting in Washington DC you can see
many people out there with masks on
which gives me some degree of comfort
that people are taking this very
seriously Thank You Houston Rosen
senator Leffler thank you all for being
here and for your service Admiral Jerrod
before I start my questions I want to
recognize your new role as the US
Representative to the World Health
Organization mitigating a resurgence of
this pandemic will take global
cooperation in order to do that we need
accountability and transparency at the
w-h-o this organization was established
to ensure the timely flow of accurate
unbiased information on global health
emergencies just as this performance
reforms must be made in order to restore
the trust that we need here I hope
you'll work with our allies to push for
these reforms this question I have two
questions the first one is for dr.
Redfield and and dr. Redfield Georgians
are wondering how we got here today
1,400 deaths a third of Georgia's
workforce out of work I'm incredibly
concerned about the cover-up and the
misinformation coming from China and
their efforts to suppress life-saving
information at the outset of this
outbreak as we can sit as we continue to
reopen our economy safely we have to
take steps to ensure that another
outbreak cannot take hold of the world
in this way I understand CDC has worked
with the Chinese CDC on global health
security for decades can you comment on
the level and the timing of the
information that you received and relied
upon from your
Chinese counterparts as this virus
emerged well thank you very much senator
and I want to echo how important global
house security is as a national security
priority for this nation and we're gonna
need to be able to be able to respond to
that as long as we are a nation CDC has
had relationships with countries around
the world we have offices in over 45
countries right now people in over 60
and one of those happens to be China
where we have a US CDC that's with the
Chinese CDC we've worked together for
four decades particularly on influenza
and emergent infectious diseases and
that has been a very productive
collaborative scientific scientific
interaction when this original outbreak
of pneumonia of unknown etiology came
from the original seafood market
obviously discussions with US personnel
that being with Chinese CDC I personally
had discussions as early
I think CDC did it anywhere and myself
can you arey third with the counterpart
he discussed this at a South scientific
level we had very good interaction I
think the broader Chinese government
level thank you dr. Redfield I have a
final question for each of our great
witnesses today and it's one that my
constituents often ask me the mainstream
media and indeed some of my colleagues
in the Senate seemed to want to paint
each of your relationships with our
president during this wartime effort is
confrontational and lacking consensus
can you categorically say here to the
American people today whether this is
true or untrue from your testimony today
I've seen a very coordinated effort to
address this with the administration to
combat this pandemic can you give me a
sense of whether this character is what
the characterization is really is
whether it's true or untrue thank you
I'd ask dr. pouchy to answer that first
no there is certainly not a
confrontational relationship between me
and the president as I mentioned many
times I give advice opinion based on
evidence-based scientific information he
hears that he respects it
he gets opinions from a variety of other
people but in no way in my experience
over the last several months has there
been any confrontational relationship
between us
thank you dr. Redfield dr. Hahn again I
but echo with dr. Pratt you said then
we're there to give our best public
health device and that's what we do it
grounded in data in science and I've
always felt free to give the best public
health advice that I think needs to be
given at the time and it's always been
done in a very professional level
senator Leffler this is Steve Hahn I do
not have a confrontational relationship
have not had a relationship for the
president he asks questions I have given
him my honest answer is rooted in data
in science and then he's listened
respectfully to those incorporating that
into his decision-making and Brett sure
why I have nothing else but to echo my
colleagues we work very closely together
on all the scientists all the physicians
of course ambassador birx other
scientists within our group we have a
very productive working relationship
with each other and also with the
president and vice president
it would not be confrontational and I
certainly feel that we have the ability
to honestly state our opinions and
recommendation and that's been that way
since the beginning Thank You senator
Leffler senator Murray do you have
closing comments I I do and if it's
already I have a couple of two quick
questions
sure well thank you you know a doctor
Gao Qi well president Trump and
otherwise there is no question that an
essential part of reopening our economy
successfully developing and distributing
a vaccine for Koba 19 we need to plan
now as you deploy a vaccine once it's
proven safe and effective but it is
absolutely crucial this planning process
from the clinical trial to distribution
and administration recognizes and
addresses racial and ethnic disparities
in our healthcare system that we all
know for too long have been overlooked
and unacknowledged in this country and
we have to ensure equitable access
access to this vaccine for everyone
dr. Fauci let me start with you what
steps is NIH taking to make sure that
clinical trials for kovin 19 back to
vaccines and therapeutics account for
racial and ethnic disparities yeah thank
you very much that's a very relevant
question senator Murray and in fact in
the design of our clinical trials and
the sites that we've chosen in our
clinical trial Network it's going to be
very representative of being able to get
minority populations and patient
populations at most risk to be part of
the trial so that we know during the
trial what the relative efficacy as well
as potential adverse events is something
we started back in the days of HIV when
we tried to get good demographic
representation and we're going to do
that with these girls thank you thank
you and dr. Horne
tell me what steps FDA is taking now to
make sure the United States is prepared
to produce a sufficient number of
vaccines including the necessary
manufacturing supply chain capacity for
supplies like viola stoppers and
syringes Thank You senator this is an
effort that started as a partnership
with the vaccine developers and the NIH
and their efforts so one of the most
important things ma'am has been the data
transparency sharing of data both of the
agency NIH and with the manufacturers so
we can understand what the capacities
are what the needs are from the supply
chain and then how to actually share
that so that if one manufactures vaccine
doesn't go forward we can use the
capacity of that and
for another manufacturer's vaccine I'm
very happy to report that the work of
dr. marks inductive ouchies group has
led to that sort of effort we are we've
developed as I mentioned before this
Gantt chart that describes all the steps
that go forward with vaccinations
including those supplies you described
it is somewhat complicated ma'am and
that we may very well have hopefully
five to seven different candidate
vaccines that may need different
supplies associated with them but we've
been upfront identifying no supplies
where they're available and then working
with the manufacturers to make sure that
they are available okay thank you thank
you very much mr. chairman thank you and
thank you to all of our witnesses for
joining us today it is really clear to
me that we have more work to do before
we can safely get back to work and
school and some semblance of normal life
in our country we still need testing to
be fast free and everywhere and we need
the White House lay out a detail
national plan to make that happen
we still need adequate personal
protective equipment both for our
healthcare workers and for workers that
our businesses and at schools when the
time comes we still need guidance from
our experts
so our communities have the information
that they need to reopen schools and
businesses safely confidentially
confidently and complete competently and
so public health workers and health care
providers have the information they need
to keep their patients and communities
safe and while experts have been clear
that the day we can safely reopen may be
a ways off there's plenty for us to do
in the meantime goes to plan ahead for
example to make sure that once we have a
safe and effective vaccine we can
produce and distribute it to everyone
quickly equitably at no cost and to
address the immediate challenges for
example making sure there are
appropriate mental health resources for
everyone who's coping with the
challenges that are prevented presented
by this virus from the stress of
physical isolation loss of income to the
trauma anxiety of patients and workers
who've been on the frontlines so I'm
gonna keep pressing Congress and the
White House to divide the action
leadership that our communities need and
I hope mr. chairman that we'll continue
to have the opportunities like this here
directly from the experts and asked
pressing questions about how to get our
country through this crisis it's clear
we've got a lot further to go a lot more
to do and so I hope that as our efforts
continue we'll be able to bring if any
of you back our witnesses for another
hearing soon and again thank you to all
of you for joining us today
thank you senator Murray I've got a
clarification question and a couple of
quick comments and then we'll well thank
the witnesses and wind up hearing my
clarification is I want to make sure I
didn't create some confusion by the way
I asked the question about going back to
school I asked dr. Fauci first about
treatments and vaccines and dr. Admiral
jalaw second about testing what I
thought I heard was that dr. Fauci said
that vaccines are coming as fast as they
ever have but it'll it'll be later in
the year at the earliest before we see
yeah but there's some treatment some of
that that have that are modest whether
promising there could be more but that
that doesn't mean you shouldn't go back
to school that that that would be more
or testing strategy am I right dr. Fauci
you didn't you didn't say you shouldn't
go back to school because we were all
dead nothing absolutely not mr. chairman
what I what I was referring to is that
going back to school would be more in
the realm of knowing the landscape of
infection with regard to testing and as
Admiral Joss said it would depend on the
dynamics of the outbreak in the region
where the school is but I did not mean
to imply at all any relationship between
the availability of a vaccine and
treatment and our ability to go back to
school you're quite correct and what I
heard from Admiral Jerrod was that
you're ramping up current technologies
you are hopeful for dr. Carlin dr.
Collins shark tank and the National
Institutes of Health but in any event
you would expect to have the capacity in
the fall of 40 to 15 May in tests a
month and that ought to be adequate for
the principal of a middle school or even
the Chancellor of a campus to divine
design a testing strategy that could
provide for example a antigen quick yes
the screen all the students in the
school if necessary Zachary
yes sir mr. chairman and again we want
to make as many tests available as as
absolutely possible what I what I said
is what I feel comfortable with knowing
the production schedules being in the
position of being able to work with the
FDA and CDC that we should have 40 to 50
we will have 40 to 50 million tests
available per month that need to be
deployed in a smart strategic way
depending on the dynamics you know in
that area and in that region I'm still
having testing even widely does not
nullify the need that we're going to
have to change our practices in terms of
sanitation personal cleanliness distance
staying facemask things like that given
what the dynamics could be the given
well thank you for those comments
because given the given that number of
tests that will be available in say
three months or as we ramped up to that
number three months from now that should
give every principal every every every
Chancellor of every college campus and
again we have about 5,000 campuses and a
hundred thousand schools a some
reassurance that testing as well as the
common sense hygiene practices you
talked about could be used to develop a
strategy for reopening school for school
in August and then two quick comments
one is Senator Murray talked about the
national plan which was in the
legislation that we all voted for it
there's a little bit of a push and tug
between what's national or what's
federal what Washington should do and
what the state should do I've always
thought it's a mistake to say federal
calls national in other words over 19 is
clearly a national problem but that
doesn't mean the federal government's
supposed to do everything for example in
testing the law actually requires states
tell you Admiral draw what their plans
are what their needs are and then you
said that during the month of May you
had a series of state plans that
identified 12 and a half million yes and
you thought you could help meet that on
the other hand you've also noticed an
efficiency in the marketplace for some
supplies so the federal government is
buying those and allocating them to the
state so we don't want to get in a
situation where everyone's or was
telling all the states what do governor
lee in Tennessee doesn't really want you
to tell him what to do he wants to tell
you what he's doing and let you comment
on it I don't think Governor Cuomo wants
president Trump tell him what to do so a
pushing tug between what Washington does
and what states do I think we have a
testing contact tracing isolating
national strategy and plan led by the
governor's designed by the federal
government as a national effort another
national effort clearly is to do the
research for the treatments and the
vaccines of what we've heard today is
that's coming along on a faster track
than we've ever seen ever seen before
finally I want to reiterate I thought
this was a very helpful hearing I think
the Senators for their questions I think
anybody who took the time the watch
would be impressed by the diversity of
opinion and the honest answers we got
from four really remarkable experts who
are in the midst of this every day I
want to re-emphasize what I said earlier
that I intend to make sure that we focus
senator murray suggested we need to have
more hearings i agree with her and as we
deal with this pandemic we need to make
sure we're ready for the next one what
can we learn about faster treatments and
vaccines for the next month what can we
learn about the stockpile well I want to
be in it you ought to be managing for
the next one what can we learn can we
learn anything about having
hospital bed so we don't have to shut
down hospitals and bankrupt them and
patients out in order to create beds for
sick people from the pandemic what about
states and hospitals that sell off their
PPE in between pandemics how do we keep
our focus in between pandemics when
we're have so many important things to
be worried about this country how do we
make sure that we in Congress sustain
and fund all the things that we need to
do so and and I want to make sure that
we do that this year I mean we our
collective memory is short so while
we're all worried about this we need to
not only deal with this crisis but get
ready for the next I thank the witnesses
for their extra time I hope they get a
sense that our job we see is to create
an environment in which you can succeed
because if you succeed our country
succeeds which is what we desperately
want the hearing record will remain open
for 10 days members may submit
additional information for the record
within that time if they would like
thanks to everyone for being here today
hearing is adjourned thank you very much
mr. chairman thank you senator Murray
pretty sure
you